THE SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETTA ASHBY, HACKINGS
BECKER, BLAKE SPEAR, BRADFORD,
CAVALLERO, CORTESI, DOLLY DODD,
BAGMAN GLASER, GONZALES, GROVE.
OH, JONES LAYERED. LEMON MCGUIRE
, MENJIVAR MEN NEWMAN WHEN NILO
BY THE YEAR PORTANTINO BROTH
RUBIO, SUHARTO SKINNER, SMALLER
QUIVERS STERN. HAMBURG WAHAB
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS OF QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELE GORMAN, AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. MR GORMAN. SO LET US BRING
OURSELVES INTO GOD'S PRESENCE ON
THIS BEAUTIFUL SPRING DAY. THE
MYSTIC JULIAN OF NORWICH WAS
IMMERSED IN THE TRAUMAS AND
TRIBULATIONS OF THE 14TH
CENTURY. TODAY WE PRAY FROM HER
EXPERIENCE OF GOD'S REVELATIONS
TO HER. USING THE ATTITUDES OF
AWAITING ALLOWING, ACCEPTING AND
ATTENDING. MERCIFUL AND
MYSTERIOUS GOD. WE AWAIT YOUR
DIVINE PRIVATE DENT'S THE
PROMISE OF YOUR FAITHFUL TENDER
LOVE. WE AWAIT THIS DAYS,
REVELATION. CURIOUS TO DISCOVER
THE SURPRISES IT OFFERS. WE
ALLOW OUR HEARTS TO OPEN AND
RECEIVE YOUR LOVING GAZE. WE
ALLOW YOUR GAZE TO REST ON OUR
HEARTS. WE ACCEPT THE CALL
INTERESTED TO US? WITH ALL THE
BLESSINGS AND CHALLENGES THERE
IN. WE ACCEPT OUR INCOMPLETENESS
OUR VULNERABILITIES AND OUR
GIFTS. WE ATTEND TO OUR PORTION
OF THE SUFFERING WORLD. WE
ATTEND TO THE TASK THAT IS OURS
AS WE SERVE THE EMERGING
WHOLENESS OF CREATION. MAY WE BE
TRANSFORMED BY OUR OPENNESS TO
THE MYSTERY OF EACH NEW DAY.
AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE TO OUR FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
OUR SENATE FLOOR SESSION THIS
MORNING. UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. FIRST RECOGNIZED PRO TIM
ATKINS. MEMBERS. HOW ARE YOU
DOING?
TALKING TO ME. YOU ARE PRO TEM
ATKINS. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES. GOOD MORNING. I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE SOMEONE WHO IS VERY
FAMILIAR TO MOST OF US WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THIS BUILDING FOR SOME
TIME NOW, AND THAT IS MR JAMIE
TAYLOR, AND I'LL DO SOMETHING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT. INTRODUCE HIS
GUEST RIGHT RIGHT NOW AND THEN
I'LL GO INTO SOME COMMENTS. WE
HAVE HIS WONDERFUL WIFE, SPOUSE.
CARMEN TAYLOR IS HERE. TWO
DAUGHTERS, CATALINA TAYLOR AND
CAMILLA TAYLOR. WE HAVE HIS
SISTER, LAUREN ROW AND BROTHER
IN LAW, TYRONE ROW AND OF COURSE
, NICE. TINSLEY ROBE RIGHT HERE,
AND I ALSO KNOW SOMEWHERE BACK
HERE OR THERE SHOULD COME UP IS,
UM, THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDIES. THIS WOULD BE LEONORE
ELLING, AND SHE IS HIS FORMER
BOSS. UM AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CAPITAL CAPITAL
FELLOWS PROGRAM. SO AS I SAID
JAMIE TAYLOR IS KNOWN TO MANY AS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE SENATE
FELLOWS PROGRAM. HE'S HELD THAT
TITLE SINCE 2018 AND RECENTLY
STEPPED DOWN TO ACCEPT A NEW
ROLE AS THE SENATE'S FIRST
DIRECTOR OF DIVERSITY, EQUITY
AND INCLUSION. CONGRATULATIONS
JAMIE. JAMIE IS UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED FOR THIS ROLE, THIS
NEW ROLE THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE OF
HIS EXPERIENCE AS THE FELLOWS
DIRECTOR AND HIS PREVIOUS
SERVICE TO THE SENATE IN THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE'S OFFICE
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW HIM,
LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT JAMIE. HE WAS RAISED IN
OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA AND IS PROUD
OF HIS ROOTS THERE. HE'S A
GRADUATE OF SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY, WHERE HE MAJORED IN
AFRICANA STUDIES. HE ALSO HAS A
MASTER OF SCIENCE IN LAW AND A
CERTIFICATE IN MEDIATION FROM
MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW AFTER
GRADUATING FROM SAN DIEGO STATE,
HE WORKED FOR ONE OF OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUES, SENATOR AT BUT AT
THAT TIME CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
JUAN VARGAS ON THE SAN DIEGO
CITY COUNCIL, AND THAT'S WHERE I
HAD THE HONOR TO MEET JAMIE. WE
WERE STAFFERS TOGETHER ON THE
10TH FLOOR. OF CITY HALL. IN
SOME REALLY GOOD DAYS. I WORKED
FOR CHRISTINE KEHOE. HE WORKED
FOR JUAN AND WE ENJOYED THAT
TIME. I THINK QUITE A LOT. HE
BEGAN HIS SERVICE TO THE SENATE
IN 2001 IN HIS PREVIOUSLY STATED
HE WORKED FOR THE SECRETARY OF
THE SENATE OFFICE FROM 2004 TO
2018. AS THE PRINCIPAL FILE
CLERK. HE BECAME WELL KNOWN FOR
HIS COMMITMENT TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
PROCEDURES OF THE SENATE. AND
HIS ABILITY TO WORK WITH BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE. JAMIE HAS
UNMATCHED INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE AND WAS ALREADY DEEPLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE SENATE'S INNER
WORKINGS WHEN HE TOOK ON THE
ROLE OF THE SENATE FELLOWS
PROGRAM DIRECTOR IN 2018. BY
THEN, HE ALREADY KNEW, WELL, THE
POLITICS AND THE PROCESS OF
GETTING EFFECTIVE LEGISLATION
PASSED. HE SUPPORTED THE SENATE
FELLOWS AS THEY WERE TASKED WITH
ADVANCING IMPORTANT POLICIES.
THAT AFFECT REAL CALIFORNIANS.
HE IMPARTED IN THEM THE SAME
VALUES HE LEARNED, MAINTAINING
STRONG RELATIONSHIPS BEING
HONEST AND TRANSPARENT AND
STAYING TRUE TO ETHICAL
STANDARDS. THIS IS IMPORTANT
GUIDANCE FOR SENATE FELLOWS, AND
I THINK ALL OF YOU HAVE HAD THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE MENTORSHIP
THAT JAMIE HAS GIVEN TO EACH OF
THEM OVER THE YEARS. IN THEIR 11
MONTHS HERE, AND THEY BECAME
ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS. HE ALSO
MADE SURE THE FELLOWS PROGRAM
ADDRESSES THE PARTICIPANTS.
MENTAL HEALTH, WHICH WAS REALLY
CRITICAL, ESPECIALLY DURING
COVID. HE OFTEN GOES ON TO
MAINTAIN THAT MENTORSHIP
RELATIONSHIP WITH MANY OF THE
FELLOWS BEYOND THE PROGRAM AND
REMAINS A TRUSTED ADVISOR TO
THEM. MANY FELLOWS GO ON TO
SERVE AN IMPORTANT ROLES IN THE
LEGISLATURE, SUCH AS LEDGE
DIRECTORS, CHIEFS OF STAFF, MANY
GO ON TO BECOME ELECTED
OFFICIALS THEMSELVES. ALL THIS
TO SAY THAT JAMIE'S MENTORSHIP
CONTINUES TO HAVE LASTING VALUE
TO OUR INSTITUTION LONG BEYOND
THE PROGRAM'S COMPLETION. DURING
HIS TIME AS DIRECTOR, HE WAS
PASSIONATE ABOUT ENSURING THAT
THE FELLOWS PROGRAM WAS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND INDUSTRIES THAT
SHAPE CALIFORNIA. THIS AND HIS
DEDICATED LONG TERM SERVICE TO
THE SENATE MAKES HIM UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED FOR THIS NEW ROLE AS
SENATE DIRECTOR OF DIVERSITY,
EQUITY AND INCLUSION. I'M
THRILLED TO SEE HIM TAKE THE
LEAD ON FURTHERING CULTURE OF
DIVERSITY, INCLUSIVITY AND
EQUITY HERE IN OUR SENATE. I
HAVE NO DOUBT ABSOLUTELY NO
DOUBT HE WILL EXCEL IN THIS NEW
POSITION. LET'S WISH HIM WELL
TODAY. THANK HIM FOR HIS MANY
YEARS OF SERVICE AND LEADERSHIP
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HIS
CONTINUED SERVICE IN THE SENATE,
AND I HAVE A RESOLUTION TO
PRESENT TO HIM TODAY.
NOW WE'D LIKE TO INVITE ALL
MEMBERS TO COME JOIN THE
PHOTOGRAPH IF THEY WISH.
OKAY, MEMBERS. UH, NEXT STEP ON
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
NEWMAN. FACE GIFT, SENATOR
NEWMAN YOUR ATTENTION MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUE UH, I AM PROUD TO NOTE
THAT WE HAVE WITH US TODAY IN
THE SENATE GALLERY DIRECTLY
BEHIND ME AND ABOVE ME, 18 VERY
TALENTED AND DEDICATED
ADMINISTRATORS, FACULTY AND
STAFF FROM THE LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY OF THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, A YEAR LONG PROGRAM
FOR HONING THE SKILLS OF
IDENTIFIED LEADERS OF 0 CC C. D
S FACULTY, FULL TIME CLASSIFIED
STAFF AND ADMINISTRATORS. THESE
DEDICATED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROFESSIONALS HAVE MADE TIME IN
THERE OTHERWISE VERY BUSY LIVES
TO ENHANCE THEIR ADVOCACY
KNOWLEDGE. LEADERSHIP ABILITIES.
AND PROFESSIONAL SKILLS. THE
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY CURRICULUM
FOCUSES ON CURRENT ISSUES AND
MANAGEMENT BEST PRACTICES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IN
SUPPORT OF ITS BROADER AIM OF
ENSURING THE DISTRICT'S
RESPONSIVENESS TO THE
CONTINUALLY EVOLVING ECONOMIC
AND SOCIETAL DYNAMICS AFFECTING
ITS CAMPUSES. IT'S STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN OFFERING A WARM CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WELCOME TO THE
PARTICIPANTS OF THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT LEADERSHIP ACADEMY.
THANK YOU. WELCOME. WELCOME TO
THE SENATE. MEMBERS TODAY IS AN
UNUSUALLY SPECIAL DAY FOR ONE OF
OUR OWN A COLLEAGUE. IS
CELEBRATING HIS BIRTHDAY TODAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND WISHING A
GREAT BIRTHDAY DAY TO SENATOR
PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NEXT. TWO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING BILL
FROM THE WITH FLOOR AMENDMENTS
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. THAT'S A
DASH 42 A B 610. ALRIGHT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NEXT TO INTRODUCTION
AND FIRST READING OF BILLS. THE
SECRETARY WOULD PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1973 1974 9 75 9 76
9 77 9 78 AND SEND A BILL 979.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. FIRST ITEM UP IS
ITEM NUMBER ONE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT AND WITH THAT WILL
RECOGNIZE SENATOR GROVE. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES,
SKYLIGHT, AND ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF NAOMI GALLARDO
FOR THE APPOINTMENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
SHE SERVES AS CEO SLOT FOR
ATTORNEY WITH ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
EXPERIENCE SINCE 2019. SHE
WORKED AT THE C E C AS A PUBLIC
ADVISOR AND ALSO CHIEF OF STAFF
TO THE COMMISSION'S CHAIR. WHEN
I MET WITH COMMISSIONER
GALLARDO, WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE ROLE OF THE COMMISSION PLACE
AND PRICE. THE PRICE OF THE
ENERGY, INCLUDING THE DIVISION
OF THE PETROLEUM OVERSIGHT
MARKET. CALIFORNIA'S GASOLINE
PRICES ARE THE SECOND HIGHEST IN
THE COUNTRY, AND WE DISCUSSED
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE COMMISSION
, NOT PREJUDGING THE DIVISION'S
ASSESSMENT IN THE MARKET WITHOUT
PROOF, OR DATA OR ENERGY IS
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE THE POLICY
CHOICES THAT HAVE MADE BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WILL FOCUS ON THE
HARM THESE POLICIES ARE CAUSING
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. CONTINUING
DOWN A PATH OF TARGETING A
SPECIFIC INDUSTRY WITHOUT DATA,
OR PROOF IS THE RESULT OF ENERGY
POVERTY IN OUR STATE COLLEAGUES
OF NEIGHBORING STATES CAN OFFER
ENERGY FOR HALF THE PRICE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WE NEED TO FIND
OUT WHAT IT IS AND NOT PREJUDGE
THE INDUSTRY THEMSELVES. I WANT
TO THANK UM UH COMMISSIONER
GALLARDO FOR LISTENING TO THAT
AND ALSO LISTENING TO THE FACT
THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT MY
PRODUCERS IN KERN COUNTY, THEIR
POLICY THERE ARE PRICE TAKERS,
NOT PRICE SETTERS. THAT MEANS
THE GLOBAL MARKET SETS THE PRICE
AND THEN THEY DON'T HAVE CONTROL
OVER WHAT PRICE IT IS. THEY JUST
SELL THE PRODUCT FOR THE PRICE
THAT SET ON THE GLOBAL MARKET.
SO WE HAD A VERY THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION. AND I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT SHE WAS WILLING TO
LISTEN TO WHAT UM, THE
CONVEYANCE OF MY CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE WITH CREATING ENERGY POLICY
OR ENERGY, POVERTY IN THIS STATE
, AND THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE DO EVERYTHING TO MAKE SURE
THAT ENERGY IS AFFORDABLE FOR
THIS STATE, AND THEREFORE I
ASKED FOR AN I VOTE ON AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS CONFIRMED BY
50 AND THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
JANUARY 10TH. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE NOMINEE? DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. C. NONE OF THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I BROUGHT A GIRL. ALRIGHT,
ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKESPEAR
ALRIGHT, BRADFORD. CALOGERO.
ALRIGHT CORTEZ E. I DOLLY. AYE,
DODD. ALRIGHT, SO ALRIGHT,
EGGMAN. ALRIGHT GLASER.
GONZALES. GROVE. I TODDLE. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. HI, LARRY. ALRIGHT
LIMÓN. ALRIGHT MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT MEN, NEWMAN.
ALRIGHT WHEN ALRIGHT, NELLO.
ALRIGHT WHAT'S YOUR BOOK?
ALRIGHT, PADILLA. ALRIGHT
PORTANTINO. HI, ROTH. AYE,
RUBIO. SUHARTO. ALRIGHT SKINNER.
AYE, SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE, STERN.
ALRIGHT, UMBERG. HI, WAHA.
WIENER. AYE, WILK. ALL RIGHT.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALES. RUBIO.
I WILL HAVE. WHAT HAVE I. ON A
ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0. THE
NOMINEE IS CONFIRMED. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO THIRD
READING AND I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU A PREVIEW OF THE BILLS THAT
WE'RE GONNA HERE TODAY SO YOU
CAN BE PREPARED. WE'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH ABOUT 2420 OR SO ODD.
BILLS AND HERE'S THE ORDER IN
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED AND
I'LL GIVE YOU UPDATES AS WE GO
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
AFTERNOON. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER 10.
FOLLOWED BY FILE AT M 13. 1516
1718 1920. OKAY? SO THE MEMBERS
CAN BE PREPARED TO HAVE THEIR
BILLS PRESENTED. WE'LL BEGIN
FIRST WITH FILE ITEM 10 BY
SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR JOLLY THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. THE SENATE BILL 804
BY SENATOR DAILY AND RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE, SENATOR
DOLLY THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS. UH, GOOD AFTERNOON. SB
804 IS A HEARSAY TESTIMONY AT
PRELIMINARY HEARINGS BILL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE LEGAL SYSTEM
MUST BE GIVEN THE TOOLS TO
PROPERLY SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
ENFORCEMENT CIVILIANS ARE
BECOMING MORE FREQUENTLY USED
SOMETHING THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ENCOURAGED. CURRENTLY ONLY SWORN
OFFICERS CAN PERFORM. HEARSAY
TESTIMONY, MEANING IF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT CIVILIANS ARE CALLED
TO THE COURT SWORN OFFICERS MUST
REINTERVIEW OLD VICTIMS OR THOSE
VICTIMS MUST BE CALLED TO COURT
TO TESTIFY THEMSELVES. LET ME
TELL YOU WHAT THIS BILL ACTUALLY
DOES. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
AUTHORIZED LAW ENFORCEMENT
CIVILIANS WITH THE SAME EXACT
TRAINING AS A SWORN OFFICER IN
THAT TRAINING IS FIVE YEARS
EXPERIENCE OR HAVE UNDERGONE THE
POST TRAINING THE SAME AS SWORN,
UH, OFFICERS DUE TO PERFORM
HEARSAY TESTIMONY. THIS BILL IS
GOOD FOR VICTIMS BECAUSE IT
KEEPS THE VICTIM FROM HAVING TO
GO INTO COURT AND HAVE TO FACE
THEIR PERPETRATORS SOMETIME OR
RELIVE THE CRIME THAT THEY WERE
WITH THAT THAT THAT THEY WERE
HAD HAD GONE THROUGH. AH! THIS
IS THE RECENT AMENDMENTS I TOOK
AND PUBLIC SAFETY THAT'S ONE
OFFICERS AND NON SWORN OFFICER.
LAW ENFORCEMENT. CIVILIANS WHO
COMMIT PERJURY WILL BE ADDED TO
THE BRADY LIST AND THE TESTIMONY
GIVEN IS SUBJECT TO DISCLOSE THE
IMPEACHMENT EVIDENCE. THIS
CHANGE HELPS HOLD THE WITNESSES
ACCOUNTABLE AND ENSURES THAT
ONLY THE BEST AND MOST RELIABLE
TESTIMONY IS ADMISSIBLE IN
COURT. MEMBERS THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN APPROACH TO HAVING
VICTIMS ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO, UM,
HAVE THEIR TESTIMONY AND I WANT
TO REMIND YOU THE LAST THING
THAT THIS BILL AND CURRENT
STATUE TODAY. UM ONLY SWORN
OFFICERS CAN TAKE FROM THE
PERPETRATOR. THESE ARE ALL NON
SWORN OFFICERS WILL BE ABLE TO
TAKE IT ONLY FROM THE VICTIMS.
SO THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT POINT
. CURRENT LAW DOESN'T LOVE THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
ON SB 804. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DOLLY ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SAYING NO
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL, ALLEN. I BROUGHT
A GALE. ALRIGHT ARCHULETTA. AYE
ASHBY. ATKINS ALRIGHT BECKER.
BLAKESPEAR ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT CORTEZ E.
DELI. ALRIGHT, DODD. ALRIGHT, SO
NO ADMIN. ALRIGHT GLASER
GONZALES. GROW. ALL RIGHT, TODD
Ó. ALL RIGHT, JONES. ALRIGHT,
LAIRD. LEMON. ALRIGHT MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT NOW, JABBAR. MEN.
NEWMAN. I WHEN ALRIGHT, NILO.
ALRIGHT WITH YOUR BOOK. ALL
RIGHT BY THE ALRIGHT PORTANTINO.
ALRIGHT, ROTH. TRUE, I RUBIO
CIERTO. ALRIGHT SKINNER. SMALLER
QUIVERS. NO STERN. I REMEMBER.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL HAVE. WIENER?
AYE, WILK. ALL RIGHT. PLEASE
FOLLOW THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BECKER. AYE, BRADFORD. AYE,
CORTEZ E. SALAS. LAIRD. MENTION
BAR. RUBIO. AYE, SKINNER. WOW.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 2. THE
MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 13 BY
SENATOR ONE HOB SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 402 BY
SENATOR WAHAB AND EQUALLY INTO
MENTAL HEALTH SENATOR WILL HAVE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I RISE
PRESENT SP 402 AS BEFORE TO
ALLOWS LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO PURSUE COUNTY
DESIGNATION IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO INITIATE A 5150 HOLD EVEN IF
THEY ARE NOT EMPLOYED OR
CONTRACTED BY THE COUNTY.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS ON THE FRONT LINE OF
OUR DISTRICT BUILDING TRUST
BASED RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEOPLE
FACING MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES.
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS FOLLOW VERY STRICT
AND SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS TO
PLACE AN INDIVIDUAL UNDER 5150
HOLD, THE PERSON MUST BE A
DANGER TO THEMSELVES A DANGER TO
OTHERS AND BE GRAVELY DISABLED.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE MEANT TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS AND THE
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ALIKE AND ENSURE
THAT THE PERSONAL SAFETY OF
SOMEONE UNDER GROWING CRISIS
COUNTY DESIGNATION TRAINING
ENSURES THAT THE LICENSED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL HAVE
SPECIFIC TRAINING REGARDING 51
FIFTIES AND UNDERSTAND THE
GRAVITY OF INITIATING ONE AS
BEFORE. 02 ENSURES THAT LICENSED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO
DON'T WORK FOR THE COUNTY OR
CONTRACT WITH IT OR ELIGIBLE FOR
COUNTY DESIGNATION TO INSTITUTE
THESE HOLDS AS A LAST RESORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN. I VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON SB
402. TINO MICROPHONES UP,
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. EXCUSE ME A MOMENT. IT'S
THE HIDDEN MICROPHONE. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR. THE
AUTHOR, TAKE A QUESTION. DEPENDS
ON THE QUESTION, BUT SURE, I
GUESS THAT'S AN AFFIRMATIVE,
SENATOR. GROVE YOUR QUESTION
THIS BILL IN, UM IN A SENATE
HEALTH, AND THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
APPLIED TO THAT BILL. DID THOSE
AMENDMENTS GET INSERTED INTO
THIS LANGUAGE HERE ON THE FLOOR?
WHICH AMENDMENTS ARE YOU
SPECIFICALLY REFERRING TO
SPECIFICALLY ALLOWING THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS? THE COUNTY'S
WHOEVER TO DESIGNATE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING THE 5150
HOLDS? THE COUNTY IS REQUIRED TO
CERTIFY WHETHER OR NOT THIS
PARTICULAR LICENSED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL IS ALLOWED
TO INITIATE A 5150. YES, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, SIR.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? ALRIGHT SEE NON
SECRETARIES, SENATOR WILLIAM,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
ALLEN. ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A
GIRL. ARCHULETTA. HI, ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
SHAKESPEARE. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ZERO. ALRIGHT, CORTESI. HI
DAILY. DODD. ALRIGHT, SO AYE,
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALES. GROVE.
ALRIGHT, SO ALL RIGHT, JONES.
AYE, LAIRD. I LEMON? MCGUIRE
ALRIGHT MEN, JABBAR. ALRIGHT,
MAN. ALRIGHT, NEWMAN. I WIN. NÓ
NILO. ALRIGHT. WHAT'S YOUR BOOK?
AYE. ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. AYE,
ROTH. ALRIGHT RUBIO. I SEE ARTO.
AYE, SKINNER. AYE, SMALLER
CUEVAS. STERN. HI, AMBER. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL HAVE HI WIENER.
AYE, WILK. I CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BROUGH GIL. BECKER.
ALRIGHT, DOLLY! AYE. GONZALES.
SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE. VOTE OF 37
TO 1. THE MEASURE PASSES GONNA
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 15 BY
SENATOR AMBER. HE'S PREPARED,
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 92 BY SENATOR AMBERG AND
EQUALLY INTO COURTS, SENATOR
AMBERG THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES SP 90 TO EXTEND
THE SUNSET PROVISION FOR REMOTE
ACCESS IN CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS.
MANY OF YOU HAVE HEARD THIS
VERSION OF THIS BILL BEFORE THIS
SIMPLY EXTENDS THE SUNSET TO
JANUARY. 2026 REMOTE ACCESS IS
ALLOWED PARTICULARLY INDIGENOUS
TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
WITHOUT. FOR EXAMPLE, MISSING A
DAY OF WORK. I URGED I VOTE ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. I SEE AN OBJECTION OR YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. HERE. SENATOR
DURAZO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, UM, COLLEAGUES. I
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN
MY BUDGET COMMITTEE SINCE 2020.
WE HEARD FROM TRIAL COURT
EMPLOYEES ABOUT SERIOUS
DIFFICULTY HEARING UNDERSTANDING
AND TRANSLATING WITNESS
TESTIMONY REMOTELY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. TESTIMONY FROM QUART
OFFICIALS WAS THE OPPOSITE. THEY
SAID. EVERYTHING WAS FINE. AND
YET IN 2022 BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
FIVE WHICH I CHAIR RECEIVED A
PROPOSAL FOR COURTS TO UPGRADE
THEIR TECHNOLOGY. WE PROVIDED
$33 MILLION TO SUPPORT REMOTE
ACCESS IN COURTROOM PROCEEDINGS,
INCLUDING UPGRADING AUDIO AND
VIDEO EQUIPMENT IN THE
COURTROOMS DESPITE RECEIVING THE
$33 MILLION FOR TECHNOLOGY, MOST
COURTS HAVE NOT INSTALLED THE
APPROPRIATE AND NECESSARY
TECHNOLOGY. JUST YOUR COUNCIL IS
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF ADOPTING
MINIMUM TECHNOLOGY STANDARDS TO
ENSURE THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
ALLOWS FOR AN ACCURATE VERBATIM
RECORD AND A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT IS GOING ON IN
PROCEEDINGS. TECHNOLOGICAL
ACCESS AND FAMILIARITY VERY
AMONG COURT USERS. ALL INTERNET
CONNECTIONS FAILED, BUT REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS EXACERBATE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE FOR COURT USERS
WITH PORTS. UH INTERNET ACCESS.
SOME COURT USERS DON'T HAVE A
PRIVATE SPACE TO PARTICIPATE IN
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS. SOME LIVE IN
MULTIFAMILY SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY CANNOT CONTROL
INTERRUPTIONS. AS A RESULT, THE
USE OF REMOTE APPEARANCES HAS
CAUSED SEVERAL ISSUES IN THE
COURTROOM. DIFFICULTIES
DISCERNING WHO IS SPEAKING
PEOPLE SPEAKING OVER ONE ANOTHER
DIFFICULTY HEARING ALL PARTIES
DUE TO AMBIENT BACKGROUND NOISE.
FAILED INTERNET CONNECTIONS.
JUDGES SOMETIMES IGNORE COURT
REPORTERS ATTEMPTS TO STOP
PROCEEDINGS AND THEN CANNOT
CAPTURE THE RECORD. COURT
REPORTER LICENSES AND CAREERS
COULD BE IN JEOPARDY. THEY ARE
OBLIGATED BOTH BY STATUTE TO
MAINTAIN THE OFFICIAL VERBATIM
RECORD. REPORTERS CANNOT DO THIS
IF THEY CAN'T HEAR DURING
PROCEEDINGS. WITNESS TESTIMONY
MUST BE IN PERSON BECAUSE REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS INCREASED POTENTIAL
FOR TAMPERING. INTIMIDATION MAKE
A DIFFICULT TO ASSESS
CREDIBILITY AND VERIFY IDENTITY.
WE CANNOT TAKE FOR GRANTED
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST IN THE
HALLS OF OUR COURTROOMS,
INCLUDING FOR POOR PEOPLE, THE
ELDERLY AND NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS. THESE DISPARITIES ARE
EXACERBATED BY TECHNOLOGY IF WE
DO NOT HAVE STANDARDS AND
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE I SUPPORTED
MY COLLEAGUE, THE AUTHORS BILL
IN 2021 SB 241 TO ENACT UNTIL
JULY OF THIS YEAR. OF LAST YEAR,
A FRAMEWORK FOR THE USE OF
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY IN CIVIL
CASES. UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL
IS MOVING FORWARD. IT SHOULD
HAVE GREATER INCLUSION OF THE
ALL THE DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE HAD
WITH COREY PORTER'S INTERPRETERS
AND CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEYS.
THERE'S NO NEED TO EXPEDITE THIS
BILL. WE NEEDED THOUGHTFUL,
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO MAKE
SURE ALL PARTIES IN OUR JUDICIAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM ARE REPRESENTED.
ALTHOUGH WE MORE PROCEEDINGS
OFFER CONVENIENCE FOR SOME
INDIVIDUALS, JUSTICE REQUIRES
ACCURACY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR TERRAZZO AND MY
APOLOGIES FOR NOT SENIOR
MICROPHONE. EARLIER ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS, DISCUSSION DEBATES.
SEEN ON SENATOR AMBER G. MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
AND THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES. I KNOW THAT'S
BEEN ISSUE OF IMPORTANCE AND
ENGAGEMENT. UM FOR MY COLLEAGUE.
LET ME JUST ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS. FIRST, THE CONCERN
WITH RESPECT TO THE INDIVIDUAL
DEFENDANT. AN INDIVIDUAL
DEFENDANT WISHES TO BE PRESENT.
THAT INDIVIDUAL DEFENDANT HAS A
RIGHT TO BE PRESENT ME EMPHASIZE
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL DEFENDANT
HAS A RIGHT TO BE PRESENT REMOTE
ACCESS, NO REMOTE ACCESS
APPEARANCE WILL EVER BE REQUIRED
. NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RECORD IS ACCURATE. BILL
REQUIRES A COURT REPORTEDLY
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
COURTROOM WENT TESTIMONY IS
BEING PRODUCED. THAT COURT
REPORTER CAN STOP THE
PROCEEDINGS IF HE OR SHE CANNOT
HEAR AND CANNOT PROPERLY REPORT
OR TRANSCRIBED. THE ATTORNEYS,
BOTH FOR THE PROSECUTION, AS
WELL AS THE DEFENSE CAN ALSO
HALT THE PROCEEDINGS AS WELL AS
THE JUDGE IN TERMS OF ACCESS,
REMOTE ACCESS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR INDIGENOUS, AND
THAT'S WHY VIRTUALLY EVERY
PUBLIC LAW INSTITUTION IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT REPRESENTS
INDIGENTS SUPPORTS THIS BILL,
PARTICULARLY FOR THE ELDERLY.
UM, OFTENTIMES, THOSE OF YOU WHO
PRACTICE KNOW THAT SOMETIMES THE
COURT APPEARANCES ONLY FIVE
MINUTES. IF YOU ARE, FOR EXAMPLE
, HOMEBOUND, AND YOU HAVE TO
MAKE ARRANGEMENTS TO GO TO COURT
FOR FIVE MINUTE APPEARANCE.
THAT'S INCREDIBLY ONEROUS. THE
SAME IS IF YOU'RE IN URGENT, AND
YOU HAVE A JOB. THE DOCKS YOUR
WAGES IF YOU MISS A DAY OF WORK,
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I
ASKED THAT THE SUNSET THE
EXTENDED THE SUNSET CAUSES THIS
BILL TO EXPIRE THIS YEAR. I
URGENT I VOTE ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I BROUGHT A GILL.
ARCHULETTA. ASHBY. ALRIGHT
ATKINS? AYE. BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ZERO. ALRIGHT CORTEZ E. ALRIGHT,
DOLLY! ALRIGHT, DODD. I DO NOT
SO NO ADMIN. AYE, GLASER.
GONZALES. GROW. ALRIGHT, SO ALL
RIGHT, JONES. AYE, LAIRD. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE ALRIGHT MEN, JABBAR. ALL
RIGHT, MAN. NEWMAN. I WHEN
ALRIGHT, NILO. ALRIGHT. WHAT'S
YOUR BOOK? ALRIGHT PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ALL RIGHT, ROB.
RUBIO. ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE
ALRIGHT SKINNER. AYE, SMALLER
CUEVAS. STERN. I AM BERG. HI.
AYE, WIENER. AYE, WILK. HI.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE MORE TIME. BROUGH GIL. AYE,
ARCHULETTA. BRADFORD. AYE
GONZALES MEN. NO SMALL WILK.
SENATOR DURAZO. IS THAT OR
RECORDED CORRECTLY, THAT WAS, I
SAID, NOT VOTING. OKAY VERIFY
THAT IS IT NOT VOTING APOLOGIES.
ALRIGHT MEMBERS THAT ANYONE ELSE
WISH TO CAST A VOTE ON THIS
BEFORE WE CLOSE THE ROLE. SEE
NONE MEASURE PASSES 35 TO 1.
GONNA MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEMS 16
SENATOR CORTEZ. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 554 BY SENATOR
CORTESI AND EQUALING TWO
RESTRAINING ORDERS. SENATOR
CORTEZ, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. CURRENT LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA FIELD OUTLINE
JURISDICTIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR RESTRAINING ORDER PETITIONS.
THIS GAP OFTEN CAUSES COURSE TO
DISMISS OR DENY ORDERS WHEN
PETITIONERS ARE IN DIFFERENT
STATES EVEN IF THE SURVIVOR FLED
FOR SAFETY. S P 554 ALLOWS
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OR HARASSMENT TO PETITION FOR AN
ORDER IN A CALIFORNIA COURT,
REGARDLESS OF RESIDENCY STATUS,
THE NATURE OF ABUSE. HAS
TRANSFORMED, SO MUST OUR LAWS.
MODERN TECHNOLOGY PROVIDES
PERPETRATORS OF VARIETY OF NEW
TOOLS TO HARASS IMPROVEMENT,
PROMOTE VIOLENCE AGAINST
SURVIVORS, EVEN FROM DISTANCE.
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL IS
TREMENDOUS INTERCEDE. VIOLENCE
IS NOW THE NORM, NOT THE
EXCEPTION. PERPETRATORS HAVE NO
BORDERS. NEITHER SHOULD HAVE
SURVIVORS PROTECTION. THE BILL
IS SPONSORED BY THE NATIONAL
CAMPAIGN. RESTRAINING ORDERS
WITHOUT BORDERS. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CORTEZ ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ALRIGHT, I'LL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED, SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALRIGHT. I
BROUGHT A GIRL. HI, ARCHULETTA.
AYE, ASHBY. ALRIGHT ATKINS.
ALRIGHT BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ALRIGHT, CABALLERO. ALRIGHT,
CORTESI. ALRIGHT, DOLLY! NO,
DAD. ALRIGHT DO THAT SO HI,
EGGMAN. ALRIGHT GLASER.
GONZALES. GROVE. TODD Ó. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. NO, LORD. HI,
LEMON. ALRIGHT MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT MEN. ALL
RIGHT, NEWMAN, I WIN. NÓ NILO.
NO JO'BURG. BY THE PORTANTINO
ALL RIGHT, ROB. RUBIO. I SEE OUR
TOE. ALRIGHT SKINNER. ALRIGHT,
SMALLER CUEVAS. I STERN HI,
AMBER. ALRIGHT WELL, HOW HI
WIENER. WILK. NO. IT'S CALLED
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALES.
GROW. NO. BUT CHILD WORK. BY THE
.
SENATOR CORTEZ MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 17. THAT'S SB 689 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 689 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR IN EQUALLY
INTO COASTAL RESOURCES, SENATOR
BLAKE SPHERE THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 689, WHICH
WILL REDUCE UNNECESSARY DELAYS
IN THE BUILDING OF BIKE LANES
ALONG CALIFORNIA'S COASTLINE IN
ALREADY DEVELOPED AREAS. DURING
MY TIME AS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF IN SANITAS, NEEDING TO AMEND
THE LCP, OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE
LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM IN ORDER
TO BUILD A PROTECTED BIKE LANE
PROJECT RESULTED IN A DIFFICULT,
EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING AND AT
TIMES NEEDLESSLY CONTENTIOUS
PROCESS. IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US
AS POLICYMAKERS TO ENSURE GOOD
GOVERNANCE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND ELIMINATE BUREAUCRATIC
HURDLES THAT MAY PREVENT OR
PROLONGED PROJECTS THAT PROVIDE
A NET POSITIVE TO SOCIETY AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT. SB 689 DOES
JUST THAT, AND IT WILL IMPROVE
THE EFFICIENCY AND
RESPONSIVENESS OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF BIKE LANES. THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IS OFFICIALLY NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL, AND IT IS
SUPPORTED BY MANY CITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
PLAGUE SPEAR RECOGNIZE SENATOR
NGUYEN. THANK YOU. IN CHARGE OF
FIVE CAN YOU HEAR ME? I OKAY?
SORRY. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY TO PROPOSE AN
AMENDMENT TO SP 689 TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF RETAIL DEATH. SO
WE NEED ACTUALLY HOLD ON.
SENATOR NGUYEN. UM LET'S HAVE
THE SECRETARY. READ YOUR
AMENDMENTS, OKAY? SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ AMENDMENT BY SENATOR
WINS THAT ONE. SENATOR NGUYEN.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. WE NEED
ACTION TODAY. I'M INTRODUCING AN
OVERDUE MEASURE THAT WOULD MAKE
SURE SERIAL THIEVES FACE FELONY
CHARGES HERE AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. CRIME BASIC ITEMS
LIKE SHAMPOO AND TOOTHPASTE, ALL
LOCKED UP YET THIEVES ROAM FREE
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT CANNOT
EFFECTIVELY PURSUE, PROSECUTE
AND PENALIZE THESE CRIMINALS.
CALIFORNIANS END UP PAYING
HIGHER COST IS RETAIL THEFT IS
RAMPANT WITH INCIDENTS LIKE IN
HUNTER BEACH JURY STORE WHERE
FAMILY HAD TO FIGHT OFFICE,
SMASH AND GRABBER OR PASADENA
STORE LOSING $500,000 WORTH OF
JURY IN A BROAD DAYLIGHT OR IN
SACRAMENTO, WHERE SHOPPERS PAY
THE PRICE ABOUT $500 MORE
ANNUALLY TO COVER THE IMPACT OF
THEFT. WE MUST SEND A CLEAR
MESSAGE TO CRIMINALS ENOUGH. IS
ENOUGH. WHILE THIS SENATE WILL
LIKELY TABLED THIS AMENDMENT I
WANT CALIFORNIA IS TO KNOW WHAT
THIS MEANS. AND I VOTE ON
ALEJO'S ON THE TABLE MEANS YOU
DO NOT SUPPORT HEARING THIS
MEASURE TO HOLD REPEAT THIEVES
ACCOUNTABLE AND NO VOTE ON A LAY
ON THE TABLE MEANS YOU DO WANT
TO DEBATE THE TOPIC OF RETAIL
THEFT TODAY TO MY COLLEAGUES. I
ASKED YOU TO PUT YOURSELF IN THE
SHOES OF OUR BUSINESSES AND
CONSUMERS. THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE EVERY DAY. WHY
DON'T WE SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS
REJECTED? LAY OFF THE LAY ON THE
TABLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NGUYEN ON THE AMENDMENT,
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR PRESIDENT, MR PRESIDENT
, THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE ADVANCING
LEGISLATION OR RETAIL THEFT THIS
YEAR, AND AS WE ALL KNOW, THAT'S
HOW THE PROCESS WORKS WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASKED TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOREIGN I
VOTE, SENATOR MCGUIRE IS MOVED
TO LAY ON THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE. IT'S A NON DEBATABLE
MOTION MAJORITY VOTERS REQUIRED,
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALRIGHT ALVARADO GIL.
ALRIGHT, ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT,
ASHBY. ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT
BECKER. ALRIGHT. SHAKESPEARE.
ALRIGHT, BRADFORD. ALRIGHT,
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT CORTEZ E. ALL
RIGHT, CHARLIE. NÓ DODD.
ALRIGHT, SO ALRIGHT, EGGMAN.
ALRIGHT GLASER GONZALES. GROVE.
NO HURTADO. ALL RIGHT, JONES. NÓ
LAIRD. I LEMON? MCGUIRE ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT, MAN. ALL
RIGHT, NEWMAN. ALRIGHT WHEN NO
NEIL Ó. NO CHILD, BORG. NO. BY
THE ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT,
ROTH. RUBIO. I SEE ARTO. NÓ
SKINNER. ALRIGHT SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. ALRIGHT.
HAMBURG. ALRIGHT WELL, HOW
ALRIGHT WIENER. WILK. NO. ONE OF
THE 31 TO 8 THAT AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN LAID ON THE TABLE WILL
RETURN NOW TO THE MEASURE AT
HAND. THIS IS SP 689 ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEN DONE,
SENATOR BLAKE SPIRIT, YOU MAY
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALRIGHT
BROTHER, GIL. AYE, ARCHULETTA.
ALRIGHT, ASHBY. ALRIGHT ATKINS.
ALRIGHT BECKER. ALL RIGHT, BLAKE
SPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD. ZERO.
ALRIGHT, CORTESI. HI, DOLLY. NÓ
DODD. I DO THAT SO AYE, EGGMAN.
ALRIGHT GLASER. ALRIGHT
GONZALES. PROBE. NO TODD Ó. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. NÓ LAIRD. I HUMAN.
MCGUIRE ALRIGHT, MENJIVAR. ALL
RIGHT, MAN. NEWMAN. ALRIGHT WHEN
. NÓ NEIL OH, NO AALBORG. NO.
BUT THE ALRIGHT PORTANTINO.
ALRIGHT, ROTH. RUBIO. ALL RIGHT,
SO YOU ARE TOE NÓ SKINNER.
ALRIGHT, SMALLER CUEVAS. HI,
STERN. ALRIGHT, HAMBURG.
ALRIGHT, WELL HA HI WIENER.
WILK. NO. VOTE OF 31 TO 8. THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NEXT TO FILL AND 18
AND WE'RE GONNA GO VIOLATE HIM.
18 THROUGH 25. IF YOU WANT TO BE
PREPARED 18 ALL THE WAY TO FILE
ITEM 25 NEXT UP, SENATOR
PORTANTINO SP 53. HE'S PREPARED,
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 53 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AND ACTUALLY INTO FIREARMS,
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS IN 2019
I AUTHORED SB 172, WHICH
ESTABLISHED A SAFE FIREARM
STORAGE REQUIREMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. SB 53 IS AN
EXPANSION OF THOSE REQUIREMENTS
BY CREATING ADDITIONAL STANDARDS
FOR SAFELY SECURING ALL GUNS IN
HOMES. EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
FIREARMS IN THE HOME TO EITHER
BE KEPT IN A LOCKED CONTAINER OR
SECURED WITH A LOCKING DEVICE
THAT PREVENTS THE GUN FROM
FUNCTIONING IF A CHILD UNDER THE
AGE OF 18 IS IN THE HOME, BUT
THERE IS NO NO BROAD REQUIREMENT
FOR THE SECURE STORAGE OF A
FIREARM BY ALL GUN OWNERS. LET
ME SAY THAT AGAIN. THERE IS NO
BROAD REQUIREMENT FOR THE SECURE
STORAGE OF FIREARMS BY ALL GUN
OWNERS. THAT'S BY FIREARM IS THE
NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
CHILDREN IN OUR COUNTRY
NATIONWIDE OVER 4.6 MILLION
MINERS LIVE IN HOMES WITH ACCESS
TO UNSECURED GUNS AND ONE IN
FIVE GUN OWNERS STORE THEIR
FIREARMS IN THE LEAST SAFE
MANNER, SUCH AS LOADED AND
UNLOCKED OVER 70% OF CHILDREN
REPORTED KNOWING THE LOCATION OF
A HOUSEHOLD FIREARM. AND ONE IN
FIVE PARENTS WHO REPORTED THAT
THEIR CHILD HAD NEVER HANDLED
THE HOUSEHOLD FIREARMS WERE
CONTRADICTED BY THEIR CHILDREN.
ADDITIONALLY, 76% OF SCHOOL
SHOOTERS OBTAINED THEIR FIREARMS
FROM THEIR PARENTS' HOME OR THE
HOME OF A CLOSE RELATIVE. SB 53
INTENDS TO REDUCE FIREARM,
SUICIDE AND UNINTENTIONAL
FIREARM INJURIES THROUGH THE
SAFE STORAGE OF WEAPONS RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT STATES THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED SAFE STORAGE LAWS
SAW A 78% DROP IN UNINTENTIONAL
SHOOTINGS COMMITTED BY CHILDREN
COMPARED TO STATES THAT DO NOT
HAVE SAFE STORAGE LAWS. THIS
DOES NOT INFRINGE UPON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT AND IT
RATHER ENSURES THAT WE HAVE SAFE
STORAGE OF WEAPONS. IF I SAY TO
YOU BLOCK YOUR CAR. WE THINK
THAT'S COMMON SENSE. WHY
SHOULDN'T LOCKING YOUR GUN? JUST
BE PRUDENT COMMON SENSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
CIERTO THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. UM.
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THE BILL,
AND THE BILL IS DUPLICATIVE.
IT'S PUNITIVE. TO THE WRONG
FOLKS. IT'S UNENFORCEABLE, AND
IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL. AS
POINTED OUT BY SOME PEOPLE
ALREADY, THE CALIFORNIA ALREADY
HAS THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
STORAGE LAWS IN THE NATION. WE
HAVE LAWS PROTECTING OUR
CHILDREN ALREADY ON THE BOOKS.
WE ALREADY REQUIRED TO ONE OF
OUR OWN ONE OF THESE DEVICES.
WHEN YOU PURCHASE A GUN, YOU'RE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO DO THAT.
ALREADY GUILTY NOW OF A CRIME.
IF YOU LEAVE A GUN ACCESSIBLE TO
CHILDREN. OUTSIDE OF ANOTHER
CRIME BEING COMMITTED. THIS IS
UNENFORCEABLE. IT'S ALSO ON ITS
FACE UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THE
REQUIREMENT THAT ANY LAWFUL
FIREARM IN THE HOME BE
DISASSEMBLED OR BOUND BY A
TRIGGER LOCK. MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR CITIZENS TO USE
ARMS FOR THE CORE, LAWFUL
PURPOSE OF SELF DEFENSE. AND HIS
HANDS UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THIS IS
ALREADY FOUND BY A FEDERAL
COURT. WHAT THIS WILL DO IS THIS
WILL CAUSE CALIFORNIA LAW THAT
IF THIS PASSES TO BE CHALLENGED
IN COURT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
THE FIDUCIARIES OF OUR CITIZENS
TAX MONEY. AND DOING SOMETHING
THAT WE KNOW IS GOING TO COST
THEM A LOT OF MONEY IN COURT
THEIR TAX MONEY AND THEN LOSING
IN COURT, WHICH WE WILL DO. IS
NOT VERY RESPONSIBLE ON OUR
HALF. SO THIS IF THIS BILL
PASSES. IT WILL LEAD TO MILLIONS
IN LEGAL FEES FOR LEGAL DEFENSE.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT REALLY IRRITATES
ME. AND EDITS THIS. MOST PEOPLE
LIVE. A LOT OF PEOPLE LIVE IN
COMMUNITIES. WHERE THEY CAN HAVE
THEIR GUN AND THEY CAN HAVE IT
SAFELY STORED BECAUSE GUESS
WHAT? THEY'LL NEVER NEED IT. SO
IT IS IRRELEVANT WHERE IT'S
STORED. BUT THERE WERE A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES OUT THERE AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES, WHICH I SERVED FOR
MANY YEARS. AND THOSE
COMMUNITIES. YOU DON'T HAVE TIME
. THE WHEN SOMEBODY BREAKS INTO
YOUR HOUSE. THEIR FIDDLE WITH
THE LOCK IN THE STORAGE. AND GET
YOUR GUN OUT BECAUSE BY THEN YOU
WILL BE DEAD. THOSE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
PRIVILEGES OF HAVING A SAFE
COMMUNITY. AND THOSE ARE THE
VERY PEOPLE THAT WERE SUPPOSEDLY
DOING THESE THESE LAST FOUR SO
THIS LAW IS UNNECESSARY. WE
ALREADY HAVE LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
IN IN IN GENERAL LAW, THERE'S
ALREADY A NEGLIGENCE CLAUSE. IF
SOMEBODY IS NEGLIGENT IN THE
HANDLING OR STORAGE OR THE
KEEPING OF A FIREARM, AND IT
RESULTS IN THE DEATH OF ANOTHER.
WELL GUESS WHAT? THEY'RE GOING
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT,
SO IT IS UNNECESSARY SO
UNNECESSARILY WE ARE FORWARDING
ARE TRYING TO ADVANCE A BILL
THAT'S GOING TO JUST COST US A
BUNCH OF MONEY AND THEN GET
THROWN OUT IN COURT EVENTUALLY,
ANYWAY. SO IT WAS POINTED OUT IN
COMMITTEE THAT I'M A PUBLIC
SAFETY GUY AND ALL MY IT MAKES
COMMON SENSE. THIS IS COMMON
SENSE. FOR SOME PEOPLE, BUT IT'S
NOT COMMON SENSE TO THE PEOPLE
THAT NEED TO USE THEIR WEAPONS
TO PROTECT THEIR SELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. FROM THE PEOPLE
THEY ARE BREAKING INTO THEIR
HOMES WERE COSTING THEM. AND SO
WHY WOULD WE NOT DO? WHY WHY
DOES IT MAKE COMMON SENSE FOR
SOME PEOPLE, BUT NOT OTHERS?
COMMON SENSE IS YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. FROM WHERE YOU
LIVE. AND WHERE YOU SEE THIS
ISSUE? SO FOR ME BEING IN PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR 35 YEARS? YES. I'VE
SEEN IT ALL. NOT ALL THE
SUICIDES ARE BY GUN. THERE ARE
PLENTY OF SPRINKLED OUT OVER THE
ARRAY OF METHODS FOR PEOPLE TO
COMMIT SUICIDE. SUICIDE IS A
DIFFERENT ISSUE THAN GUN
VIOLENCE. SUICIDE IS AN ISSUE OF
MENTAL HEALTH. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
WORKING ON. THIS IS NOT GOING TO
HELP THAT ISSUE. SO I WOULD URGE
A NO VOTE ON THIS. SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO HELP PEOPLE. BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE
CRIMINALS. OUT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
SIMPLY USING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO OWN A
GUN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SUNARTO ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEN ON
SENATOR PORTANTINO YOU MAY CLOSE
. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. COLLEAGUES. WE KNOW
THIS WORKS. WE KNOW THIS SAVES
LIVES. LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN. WE
KNOW THIS SAVES LIVES. WE KNOW
THIS WORKS. WHEN WE HAVE THE
EXAMPLE FROM OTHER STATES OF A
PUBLIC POLICY OF PUBLIC SAFETY
POLICY. THAT MAKES IT SAFER FOR
CHILDREN TO GO TO SCHOOL. AND WE
SAY, OH, IT'S GOING TO BE
INCONVENIENT TO LOCK MY GUN UP.
THAT'S NOT COMMON SENSE. THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING AS
THE SHEPHERDS OF PUBLIC TRUST OF
PUBLIC SAFETY. OF OUR CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AND WELFARE. 70% OF THE
SHOOTERS. GET THE GUN FROM
SOMEBODY THEY KNOW BECAUSE IT'S
NOT LOCKED UP. 70% REDUCTION IN
UN INTISSAR PATED. SHOOTINGS 70%
REDUCTION WHEN THIS POLICY IS
IMPLEMENTED. THIS IS NOT AN
INFRINGEMENT ON SOMEBODY'S
SECOND AMENDMENT. THIS IS A
RECOGNITION THAT GUNS KILL
PEOPLE. AND THE READILY
AVAILABLE UNLOCKED GUNS KILL
MORE PEOPLE. AND THE BEST WAY TO
MAKE IT SAFER. FOR OUR CHILDREN
TO GO TO SCHOOL. AND FOR PEOPLE
IN HOUSEHOLDS WHERE THERE IS
TRAUMA. IS TO MAKE SURE THE
WEAPONS DON'T FALL INTO THE
WRONG HANDS. AND THE WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO LOCK THEM UP. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED,
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
ALLEN. ALL RIGHT, ROGER GALE.
ARCHULETTA. AYE ASHBY. ALRIGHT,
ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER. ALL
RIGHT, BLAKE SPEAR. ALRIGHT,
BRADFORD. ALRIGHT, SO ALRIGHT,
CORTESI. ALRIGHT, DOLLY! NO DAR
SO HI, EGGMAN. ALRIGHT GLASER.
GONZALES GROVE. NO SHADOW.
JONES. NO LORD, I LIMÓN HI
MCGUIRE. MENU BAR. ALL RIGHT,
MAN. AYE, NEWMAN. HI, WEN. NO
NEIL. OH, NO TROUBLE. NO. BY THE
. PORTANTINO ALRIGHT ROTH.
RUBIO. ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE NÓ
SKINNER. AYE, SMALLER CUEVAS.
STERN. HI. I'M BERT. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL HAVE ALRIGHT WIENER. WILK.
NOW, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL. KANSEN
STARTED. GONZALES. HELLO. I
DON'T KNOW. ON A VOTE OF 27 AND
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 19. THIS IS SP
230 BY SENATOR SUNARTO.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SEND A
BILL TO 30 BY SENATOR SUHARTO
AND EQUITY INTO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. TAX LEVY
SENATOR SIART Ó. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB 230 SB 230 WOULD
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS AND HOUSEHOLDS
MAKING BELOW MEDIAN INCOME TO
DEDUCT HEALTH SAVINGS ACCOUNT
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THEIR TAXABLE
INCOME. THIS WILL GIVE WORKING
CLASS CALIFORNIANS AN ADDITIONAL
TOOL TO OFFSET THE COST OF HIGH
DEDUCTIBLES AND MAKE HEALTH CARE
MORE ACCESSIBLE. WHEN IT IS
NEEDED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE ANY DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? SEE NONE. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI. I
BROUGHT A GILL. ALRIGHT,
ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT ASHBY.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKESPEAR
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. ORTEZ.
ALRIGHT, DOLLY! ALRIGHT, DODD.
HAGMAN. ALRIGHT GLASER. ALRIGHT
GONZALES. GROVE. I HAD Ó. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. AYE, LAIRD. LEMON.
ALRIGHT MCGUIRE. MENTIONED WERE
NO MEN. AYE, NEWMAN. I WHEN.
ALRIGHT NILO. ALRIGHT, WHAT'S
YOUR BOG? ALL RIGHT BY THE
ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT,
ROTH. RUBIO. ALRIGHT. SEE ARTO.
ALRIGHT SKINNER. NO SMALLER
CUEVAS. STERN. HAMBURG. ALRIGHT,
WELL HA HI WIENER. I WELCOME
AYE. WIENER. I DON'T KNOW THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY. ATKINS.
BECKER. I SHAKESPEARE. AYE,
BRADFORD. ZERO. AYE. SO
GONZALES. LORD. NO. MCGUIRE
SMALLER CUEVAS. STERN. ON A VOTE
OF 28 TO 4. THE MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 20. SENATOR WIENER, HE
SEEMS PREPARED. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ CENTERVILLE TO 94 BY
SENATOR WIENER INOCULATING TO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR PRESIDENT. I'M COLLEAGUES. SP
294 MAY SEEM FAMILIAR TO YOU
BECAUSE THIS BODY PASSED
PREVIOUSLY AND THIS LEGISLATION
WILL INCREASE ACCESS, UH, TO
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDES FOR, UH FOLKS UNDER THE
AGE OF 26 IF HEALTH INSURANCE OF
THEIR HEALTH PLAN DENIES THEIR
REQUEST TO COVER MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT, UM IT WILL IT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY TRIGGER AN
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW OR AN
I M R. WE KNOW THAT MANY
FAMILIES DO NOT EVEN KNOW THAT
THIS APPEAL PROCESS EXISTS.
PARTICULARLY OF FOLKS FOR WHOM
ENGLISH IS NOT THE FIRST
LANGUAGE BASED ON THE DATA THAT
WE HAVE, AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WHEN INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEWS
FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
ARE REQUESTED, OVERWHELMINGLY
HEALTH PLAN LOSERS SO THIS WILL
INCREASE ACCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
MEMBERS ANY DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? SB 294 ANY DEBATES? S¼
NONE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AND ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A
GILL. ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR. BECKER. I LIKE
SPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ALRIGHT, CABALLERO. ALRIGHT,
CORTESI. ALRIGHT, DOLLY! NÓ
DODD. ALRIGHT, SO ALRIGHT,
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALES. GROW.
NO HADO. ALL RIGHT, JONES. NO,
LORD. AYE, LIMÓN. MCGUIRE
ALRIGHT, MENJIVAR. ALL RIGHT,
MAN. NEWMAN. ALRIGHT WHEN NO
NEIL Ó. NO MORE TROUBLE.
PORTANTINO ALRIGHT, ROTH. RUBIO.
I SEE ARTO. NÓ SKINNER. AYE,
SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. HI,
AMBER. ALRIGHT, WELL HA. ALRIGHT
WIENER. AYE, WILK. NO, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL. AYE. GONZALES.
WHAT'S YOUR BUG? AND A VOTE OF
31 TO 7. THE MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM. 21 WE'RE GONNA GO FILE AT
HIM. 21 THROUGH FILE ITEM 25.
VIOLATING 21 S BEFORE 80 BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 480 BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO INEQUITY INTO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS, SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. SB 480 WILL IMPLEMENT
A PILOT PROGRAM FOR CALIFORNIA
TO USE THE KOREAN MEISTER HIGH
SCHOOL SYSTEM. IN ESSENCE, THIS
SYSTEM TEACHES KIDS LARGELY
TECHNICAL AND PROFESSIONAL
CAREER SKILLS WHILE THEY'RE
STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL PROVIDES
STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT KNOW
WHETHER THEY WANT TO GO TO A
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTION INTO THE
WORKFORCE. IT PROVIDES THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN THOSE JOB
SKILLS. WHILE THEY'RE FIGURING
OUT THEIR FUTURE WHILE THEY'RE
IN HIGH SCHOOL, UM, WHEN I WAS
IN KOREA SEVERAL YEARS AGO, I
WAS MADE AWARE OF TWO OF THEIR
SYSTEMS THAT THEY USE ONE AS YOU
GO TO CLASS, MONDAY, TUESDAY,
WEDNESDAY AND YOU WORK THURSDAY,
FRIDAY ANOTHER IS YOU GO TO
CLASS FOR A MONTH. YOU WORK FOR
A MONTH. AND WHEN YOU GRADUATE,
YOU'VE LEARNED THE TECHNICAL
SKILLS OF THAT PARTICULAR
DISCIPLINE, AND THEY CALLED
COMMONLY REFERRED TO THOSE JOBS
AS NEW COLLAR JOBS. WE NEED A
TECH WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
MODEL OF PILOT ON A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY
THAT'S DOING IT WELL, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. SEE NONE. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALRIGHT BROTHER, GIL. ALRIGHT
ARCHULETTA ASHBY. AYE, ATKINS.
ALRIGHT BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ALRIGHT, CABALLERO. ALRIGHT
CORTEZ E. ALRIGHT, DOLLY! DODD.
I WOULD ALSO AYE, EGGMAN.
ALRIGHT GLASER. ALRIGHT
GONZALES. GROVE. HÌ ALL RIGHT,
JONES. LARD. I LEMON? ALRIGHT
MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT, MAN, JAMAR.
ALL RIGHT, MAN. ALL RIGHT,
NEWMAN. ALRIGHT WHEN NILO.
TROUBLE. BY THE. WHAT'S YOUR
BOOK? I BY THE EYE PORTANTINO. I
BROUGHT AYE, RUBIO. ALRIGHT. SEE
ARTO. ALRIGHT SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLER GRABBERS. AYE, STERN. I
AM BURT. ALRIGHT, WELL HA
ALRIGHT WIENER. I WELCOME AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DOLLY! GONZALES. GROVE. JONES.
AYE. WHEN NO NEIL Ó. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. ON A VOTE OF 36 TO
137 TO 1. EXCUSE ME, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 22 BY SENATOR CORTEZ.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 43 BY SENATOR CORTESI AND
RELATING TO PEOPLE RIGHTS,
SENATOR CORTESI. THANK YOU AGAIN
, MR PRESIDENT, UM AND MEMBERS
TODAY, RICE PRESENTED SENATE
BILL 43. THIS BILL WILL PROHIBIT
PRONE RESTRAINT IN ALL
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. WHICH IS A
TECHNIQUE THAT PHYSICALLY OR
MECHANICALLY RESTRAINED STUDENTS
THAT ARE FACE DOWN POSITION. THE
U. S DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
RECOMMENDED THE ELIMINATION OF
THIS DANGEROUS TECHNIQUE IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BECAUSE IT
RESTRICTS STUDENTS AIRWAYS AND
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE FATAL
AND, IN FACT HAS BEEN FATAL. BY
PASSING THIS BILL, CALIFORNIA
WILL FOLLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION RECOMMENDATIONS AND
JOIN THEM MORE THAN 30 STATES
HAVE ALREADY BEEN PRONE
RESTRAINT IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THAT BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ. ANY
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
WHEN I HEARD THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE AND I WAS MORTIFIED BY
THE MOTHER'S TESTIMONY ABOUT HER
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED CHILD
BEING IN THE PRONE POSITION FOR
HOURS AS HE DIED A SLOW, PAINFUL
DEATH. UM AND THE OTHER STUDENTS
WATCHED. UM. IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT A BILL LIKE THIS IS
NECESSARY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHO WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT THAT ANY TEACHER ANY
INDIVIDUAL WOULD PUT ANY STUDENT
IN A PRONE POSITION FOR HOURS AT
A TIME? THERE'S UM I MEAN, I
UNDERSTAND AN IMMEDIATE
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OTHER
STUDENTS AND THE TEACHER. BUT
BASED ON THE TESTIMONY THAT WAS
HAPPENING AT THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION, THIS WAS A
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE HAD A
REACTION TO SOMETHING AND TO
LEAVE THAT INDIVIDUAL IN THAT
PRONE POSITION FOR HOURS AS HE
SUFFOCATED IS HORRIFIC, UM AT
BEST. AND, UM. NOT TO GO BACK TO
A BILL I INTRODUCED LAST YEAR,
BUT I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THE
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WE SAID THAT
YOU KNOW, SO THAT STUDENTS LIKE
THIS JUST AREN'T WAREHOUSED IN
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM WHERE
PARENTS COULD USE TAXPAYER
DELIVERS OF $17,000 A YEAR TO
ALLOW THESE PARENTS TO PUT THEM
IN DIFFERENT TYPES OF LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS TO CREATE UPWARD
MOBILITY AND MAYBE A MORE A MORE
ADEQUATE FACILITY THAT WOULD
HELP THOSE THAT ARE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED. UM BE
HIGHER WAGE EARNERS AND HIGHER
LEARNERS BECAUSE THEY WOULD HAVE
SPECIALTY ATTENTION INSTEAD OF
TREATMENT LIKE THIS, AND I'M NOT
SAYING ALL SCHOOLS ARE LIKE
THIS. I JUST THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE OPTIONS OUT THERE AGAIN. I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. IT WAS HEART
WRENCHING TO LISTEN TO THAT
MOTHER TELL THE STORY OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO HER SON. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? ANY FURTHER
DEBATE, SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU
MIGHT CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEE NO OBJECTION IS 39 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES WILL MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM. 23 THIS IS SP
571 BY SENATOR ALLEN. HE'S NOT
AT HIS DESK. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 24. THIS IS, UH, I'M
SORRY. IT'S JUST I GUESS WE'LL
HEAR IT NEXT YEAR. THIS IS A
FILE ITEM. VIOLATING 24. THIS IS
SP 575 BY SENATOR WAHABI, THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 575 BY SENATOR WAHAB
EQUALING TWO UNDERAGE MARRIAGE.
SENATOR WAHAHA. THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. CALIFORNIA LACKS A
REAL UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPACT
OF CHILD MARRIAGES ACROSS THE
STATE. WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT
CALIFORNIA AFFORDS ITS CHILDREN
SOME OF THE WEAKEST PROTECTIONS
AGAINST CHILDHOOD MARRIAGE IN
THE UNITED STATES. DATA SHOWS
THAT 90% OF WOMEN WHO WERE IN
CHILDHOOD MARRIAGES, REPORT
PHYSICAL, SEXUAL OR EMOTIONAL
ABUSE. CURRENTLY CHILDREN IN THE
STATE REQUIRE THE CONSENT OF ONE
PARENT AND A COURT ORDER TO BE
MARRIED. BUT THERE ARE LOOPHOLES
IN REPORTING. CHILD MARRIAGES
WITHOUT COURT ORDERS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO BE REPORTED. SP 575
CLOSES THAT LOOPHOLE AND
REQUIRES ALL CHILD MARRIAGES TO
BE REPORTED. TO MAKE GENUINE
PROGRESS TOWARDS SUPPORTING OUR
CHILDREN. WE NEED TO IDENTIFY
THE SCALE OF THIS ISSUE. THIS
BILL DIRECTS COUNTY RECORDERS TO
ISSUE A REPORT OF ALL CHILD
MARRIAGES IN 2019 2024 TO THE
STATE REGISTRAR. THIS BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A STUDY TO DETERMINE
THE IMPACT OF EXTRALEGAL CHILD
MARRIAGES AND GATHER IT
ESSENTIAL DATA TO DETERMINE THE
SCOPE OF THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHABI ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NO
OBJECTION. EYES 39 0.
ALRIGHT, WE'RE GONNA TAKE A ROLL
CALL ON THE MEASURE. SO LET'S
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. SV 575 BY
SENATOR WAHAB. ALAN I BROUGHT A
GILL. ALRIGHT, ARCHER LETTER. I
ASHBY ALRIGHT ATKINS. AYE,
BECKER. AYE, BLAKESPEAR.
ALRIGHT, BRADFORD. ZERO.
ALRIGHT, CORTESI. HI, DOLLY.
AYE, DODD. ALRIGHT, SO EGGMAN
GLASER. AYE. GONZALES. GROVE. I
FOLLOW. ALL RIGHT, JONES. LAIRD.
I LEMON? ALRIGHT MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT, MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT, MAN.
ALRIGHT, NEWMAN. I WIN. ALRIGHT,
NILO. ALRIGHT, WELL, CHILD,
BORG. ALL RIGHT BY THE. ALRIGHT
PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT ROTH. AYE,
RODEO. ALRIGHT. SEE ARTO. HI
SKINNER. SMALL WORLD DRIVERS.
AYE, STERN. I AM BERG. ALRIGHT,
WELL HA AYE, WIENER. I WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BAGMAN. I.
GONZALES. JOHNS. SKINNER. AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0. THE
MEASURE PASSES AT THE REQUEST OF
A HIGHER AUTHORITY VERY HIGH.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM 23 SP 571 BY SENATOR ALLEN
HE SEEMS TO BE DISTRACTED.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
GO BACK TO FILE ITEM 571 THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 571 BY SENATOR ALLEN AND
ACCORDING TO FIRE SAFETY UNDER
ALAN, THE PRIVILEGED FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
YOU'RE DOING GREAT JOB TODAY. UM
PLEASED TO BE PRESENTING THIS
BILL IS BASED BILL CHARGES ARE
STATE BOARD OF FORESTRY WITH THE
TASK OF STUDYING STANDARDS
RELATED TO INGRESS AND EGRESS
FOR NEW DEVELOPMENTS PROPOSED IN
AND HIGH RISK FIRE AREAS OF THE
STATE FIRE PRONE AREAS OF THE
STATE. SO WE FIND OURSELVES IN A
BIT OF A CONFERENCE OF A CRISIS
HERE. WE CONTINUE TO NEED TO
DEVELOP ADDITIONAL HOUSING. WE
ALSO NEED TO BE MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE MAKING THESE DECISIONS
WITH THE NECESSARY CONSIDERATION
OF THE THREATS THAT SOME AREAS
POSE. LAST YEAR, OF COURSE, THE
BOARD RELEASED ITS MINIMUM FIRE
SAFETY REGULATIONS, BUT THOSE
REGULATIONS DID NOT DIRECTLY
CONSIDER A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
INGRESS AND EGRESS ROUTES
REQUIRED IN NEW DEVELOPMENTS AND
MANY AREAS OF MY DISTRICT. I'M
SURE MANY OF YOURS YOU'VE GOT
EXISTING EVACUATION ROUTES THAT
ARE REALLY GETTING POTENTIALLY
THE POTENTIAL BEING STRETCHED
THIN IN THE EVENT OF A MAJOR
WILDFIRE EMERGENCY AND WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION AND INCLUSION OF
ADDITIONAL EVACUATION ROUTES IN
NEW BUILDS, THE CONSEQUENCES
COULD BE DEADLY. SO THIS BILL
SEEKS A VALUABLE STEP BY
DIRECTING THE BOARD TO STUDY
THIS ISSUE WHILE CONSIDERING
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS LIKE
DEVELOPMENT SIZE. IF WE CONTAIN
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS, TRAFFIC
IMPACTS AND OTHERS. IT'S A WORK
IN PROGRESS. WE'RE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS NUANCE BUT
IMPORTANT ISSUE I'VE COMMITTED
TO KEEPING BOTH THE RELEVANT
POLICY COMMITTEES APPRISED OF
THE BILL MOVED FROM OUR CHAMBER
TODAY. I'VE SPOKEN WITH A COUPLE
OF YOU ABOUT SELLING CERTAIN
STANDARDS FOR MINIMUM SIZE BUILD
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON ON
SIZEABLE NEW DEVELOPMENT THAT
COULD DRAMATICALLY STRAIN OUR
ABILITY TO GET PEOPLE OUT DURING
A WILDFIRE EMERGENCY, AND THAT'S
THE GOAL OF THE BILL HERE AND I,
YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO KEEP HAVING
THESE VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ALLEN. I SEE THAT MICROPHONES UP
FROM CENTER LAIRD AND THEN
SENATOR DODD, SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU, UM YEAH. MR PRESIDENT
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT THIS IN
COMMITTEE. BECAUSE THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY WAS TASKED WITH THIS
AND THEY COULDN'T DO IT BECAUSE
THERE WERE REALLY BIG ISSUES
THAT THEY COULDN'T RESOLVE. AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES, IT SAYS
WILL FORCE YOU TO RESOLVE IT,
BUT IS SILENT IN MANY WAYS ABOUT
THE STANCE ON THOSE ISSUES. AND
IN MY DISTRICT. WE LOST 925
HOMES TO FIRE. AND SOME OF THE
INGRESS AND EGRESS IS SINGLE.
AND IF THERE'S A NEW UNDER THIS
BILL UNDER IF THERE IS A NEW
BILL, A NEW HOUSE PROPOSED IN
ANY OF THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS, MANY
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE BURNED
OUT CANNOT REBUILD. THAT WOULD
BE UNACCEPTABLE. AND I HAVE. I
HAVE BEEN DEBATING WHAT TO DO ON
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S
CONSTANTLY A WORK IN PROGRESS AS
IT'S COME BY, AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I CAN GO HOME AND NOT
FACE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE AND SAY
SORRY WE PASSED THIS BILL AND
YOU CANNOT REBUILD FROM THE FIRE
, SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT ON
THE RECORD, AND REGARDLESS OF
WHAT I DO TODAY TO ME, THAT HAS
TO BE WORKED OUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD,
SENATOR DODD. SENATOR DODD AND
THEN SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. I CONCUR WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA SANTA CRUZ IS, UH,
SOMEBODY THAT HAD A NUMBER OF
HOMES BURNED DOWN THROUGHOUT MY
ENTIRE DISTRICT. AH I REALLY
THINK THE LAST EFFORT BY THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY FRANKLY, WAS
AN ABJECT FAILURE. I HAD MANY,
MANY CASES WITH THE RULES THAT
THEY PUT FORWARD AND THEN
FORTUNATELY, WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THOSE GUIDELINES AND NOT
MANDATES OR YOU KNOW FOR COUNTY,
SO THE COUNTIES HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO BE ABLE TO DO WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO IN, YOU KNOW, IN
IN THEIR COUNTIES. I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE AND I
DID TALK TO YOU KNOW, THE AUTHOR
FROM LOS ANGELES THAT HE'LL WORK
WITH R C R C AND TRY TO GET A
MINIMUM THRESHOLD, SO THIS
DOESN'T HIT THE TYPE OF PEOPLE
THAT THE SENATOR FROM SANTA CRUZ
SUGGESTED IT WOULD. AND I AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY IT NOT ONLY WOULD
BUT IT DID, AND WE HAD A LOT OF
WORK TO DO TO GET IT TO WHERE IT
IS RIGHT NOW WHERE IT'S YOU
KNOW, KIND OF DISCRETIONARY ON
THE PART OF THE COUNTIES, BUT
THE COUNTIES ARE AFRAID BECAUSE
THEY'RE THINKING, HEY, THE
STATES GIVEN THESE RULES, AND
SOME COUNTIES DO NOT BELIEVE
IT'S DISCRETIONARY. THEY BELIEVE
THAT THAT THEY IT'S THE LAW OF
THE LAND, AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
ENFORCING IT, AND THAT'S I JUST
THINK IT'S THE WORST THING WE
COULD DO. SO WE'VE GOT TO BE
VERY, VERY CAREFUL. I WILL
SUPPORT IT TODAY. UM BUT I
PROMISE IF THIS COMES BACK LIKE
THIS ON THE FLOOR THAT I'LL GET
UP AND SPEAK OUT AGAINST THE
BILL. THANK YOU, SENATOR DODD. I
HAVE MICROPHONES FROM SENATOR
DOLLY AND SENATOR WIENER,
SENATOR DOLLY! THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS, I JUST TO
WANT TO SAY THAT SOMEBODY HAS
REPRESENTED MANY AREAS THAT HAVE
HAD FIRES. UH YOU KNOW THE
CAMPFIRE THE CAR FIRE THE DIXIE
FIRE. UM AND WE'VE HAD EGRESS
PROBLEMS AND THAT THOSE ARE
PASSED. THIS IS ACTUALLY FOR NEW
DEVELOPMENT. AND I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR THAT. BUT I WILL BE
LAYING OFF TODAY BECAUSE THE
DEVIL IS IN THE DETAILS. WE NEED
TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T PENALIZE FOLKS WHO, UM ARE
IN A IN A SPOT WHERE THEY'VE
LOST EVERYTHING AND THEN CAN'T
REBUILD AND TRUST ME. I KNOW
THAT THE SENATOR FROM SANTA CRUZ
IS TALKING ABOUT. I'VE HEARD
FROM THEM TO TRUST. THE AUTHOR
WILL WORK THOSE DETAILS OUT AS
WE GO FORWARD. HOPEFULLY, WE
WON'T SEE A LOT OF AMENDMENTS
THAT HURT FOLKS AND WE ACTUALLY
GET WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO GO,
WHICH MAKES FIRE SAFE
COMMUNITIES AWAY. THEY CAN GET
OUT AND THEY CAN STILL BUILD.
THAT'S THE GOAL HERE. SO I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR THAT. BUT
I'LL BE WATCHING THIS BILL AS IT
GOES THROUGH. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
SO WHEN THIS BILL WAS FIRST IN
PRINT AND COMING TO THE
COMMITTEE IS THE AUTHOR KNOWS I
HAD VERY, VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL. AND NOT FOR MY
WOULD HAVE BEEN A NO ON THE
BILL, AND I WANT TO REALLY THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR GREEN TO PULL
BACK AND TO TAKE MORE TIME AND
TO ACTUALLY INVOKE A PROCESS
HERE, AND I UNDERSTAND THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT PROCESS. BUT
I REALLY WANT TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
CREDIT FOR DOING THAT. BECAUSE
THE ORIGINAL BILL BILL, IN MY
VIEW WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTABLE AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR TAKING MORE TIME SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SCENE NINE. SENATOR
ALLEN, YOU MAY CLOSE EXCUSE ME.
SENATOR STERN. SORRY TO BE
BELIEVED IN THE DEBATE. I GUESS
IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DISTRICTS
WHO HAVE BEEN HIT BY FIRES LAST
MORE PROPERTIES IN THE WOOLSEY
FIRE THAN ANY FIRE OF EVERY LAST
THREE DECADES. LOST MY OWN HOME
HAD EVACUATION THAT WAS BOTCHED.
UH HUH. AND PUT A MY GRANDFATHER
IN THE HOSPITAL SO INGRESS AND
EGRESS IS AWFULLY PERSONAL AND
SERIOUS, ACTUALLY REALLY RESPECT
WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO
HERE, AND I KNOW THESE ARE
TRICKY TENSIONS OF YOU KNOW, YOU
WANNA AFTER THAT FIRE HAPPENS UP
THAT THAT LONG, WINDY ROAD. YOU
WANT TO GO REBUILD WHATEVER WAS
THERE AND A LOT OF TIMES IT'S
PEOPLE, UH, WITH VERY NICE HOMES
WHO MAYBE WANT TO GO REBUILD AN
EVEN NICER HOME. I DON'T THINK
ANY OF THIS BILL IS GOING TO GET
IN THE WAY OF THOSE PEOPLE DOING
WHAT THEY GOTTA DO. I THINK IT'S
REALLY ABOUT TRYING TO BACKDOOR.
UM BIG NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN THESE
FIRE ZONES WITHOUT ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT. SO I DIDN'T I DIDN'T
TAKE FROM THE AUTHOR'S
PRESENTATION AT ALL THAT FOR THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN HIT BY FIRES
THAT THERE'S ANY TEND TO BLOCK
THAT RE REBUILDING, BUT I THINK
WE ALL NEED TO BE SERIOUS ON
THIS FLOOR ABOUT THE INSURANCE
CRISIS AND THAT IF WE ARE GOING
TO EXPAND DEVELOPMENT DEEPER
INTO THESE FIRE ZONES, WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE AN EVEN GREATER
INSURANCE CRISIS. SO I GUESS I'M
STANDING IN SUPPORT OF SOMEONE
WHO FACED SIMILAR PROBLEMS, AND
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK.
MAYBE YOU CAN COMMENT ON THAT IN
YOUR CLOTHES. THANK YOU, SENATOR
STERN ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? C
NINE CENTRALITY MAY CLOSE I
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE. THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT. WE WERE FOCUSED ON NEW
DEVELOPMENT. SO THE KIND OF
REBUILD THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SENATOR FROM SANTA CRUZ IS
NOT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO GET AT
HERE. WE ACTUALLY HAD PROPOSED
MINIMUM STANDARDS. SENATOR FROM
NAPA AND I WERE DISCUSSING THIS
IN OUR IN OUR BILL AS ORIGINALLY
FORMULATED. TO SAY THAT WE WOULD
ONLY THIS BILL WOULD ONLY BY THE
WAY, LET'S REMEMBER IT'S JUST
ASKING THE BOARD TO STUDY THIS
ISSUE, BUT BUT EVEN THEN WE
WANTED THE MINIMUM STANDARD TO
BE THE KIND OF NEW DEVELOPMENT
THAT WOULD TRIGGER AN INCREASE
IN 40 VEHICLES THAT WOULD NEED
TO BE EVACUATED ON A DIME.
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF A
CATASTROPHIC, QUICK MOVING
WILDFIRE SO THAT YOU KNOW THE
IDEA BEING THAT WOULD BE AT 20
RESIDENTIAL UNITS OR THE
COMMERCIAL EQUIVALENT. THE WORD.
WE'RE CERTAINLY WE DON'T WANT TO
HIT PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO REBUILD.
I WANT TO MAKE THAT REALLY
CLEAR. AH, AND WE DO WANT TO
HAVE THESE MINIMUMS NOW. THE
NATURAL RESOURCE WATER COMMITTEE
WAS TOOK THAT OUT. I QUITE
FRANKLY, YOU KNOW, WE HAD, SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE SOME
SOME FURTHER NEGOTIATION WITH
THE COMMITTEE. I VERY MUCH
WELCOME YOUR ENGAGEMENT IN THAT
CONVERSATION, SENATOR. UH,
BECAUSE THEY WANT A MORE
EXPANSIVE VIEW. I'M ALSO HEARING
FROM ALL EVERYONE HERE ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. WE WANT TO REALLY
KEEP THIS TIGHT. I AGREE WITH
YOU, SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
ENGAGE THAT CONVERSATION WITH
THE COMMITTEE. BUT BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT
ENSURING THAT THAT AS WE ARE
LOOKING, YOU KNOW, AS AS FOLKS
ARE TRYING TO DEVELOP MAJOR NEW
DEVELOPMENTS INVOLVING LITERALLY
KIND OF 20. NEW HOUSING UNITS OR
MORE OR AN EQUIVALENT AH, THAT
THAT WE'RE TAKING INTO ACCOUNT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF INGRESS AND
EGRESS. IN THE CASE OF A
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE. WE SAW
WHAT HAPPENED IN PARADISE. WE'VE
SEEN OTHER CASES SUCH AS THOSE
MENTIONED BY THE SENATOR. FROM
UH FROM LOS ANGELES AND IT'S
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS HERE. UH AND IT'S WITH
THAT THAT I ASKED FOR MY VOTE.
I'LL DEBATE HAVING CEASED,
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BALANCE. ALRIGHT ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY. ALRIGHT
ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. BRADFORD. ALRIGHT,
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT CORTEZ E.
DOLLY! DODD. ALRIGHT, SO HAGMAN.
I GLASER GONZALES. GROVE.
SHADOW. ALL RIGHT, JONES.
PLAYER. LIMÓN ALRIGHT MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT MEN, JABBAR. ALL RIGHT,
MAN. ALL RIGHT, NEWMAN. I WIN.
NILO. WHAT? ALL RIGHT. WHAT
TROUBLE? HI, PADILLA. PORTANTINO
ALRIGHT, ROTH. ALRIGHT RUBIO.
ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE ALRIGHT
SKINNER. ALRIGHT, SMALL
RECOVERS. AYE, STERN. ALRIGHT
HAMBURG, HOB HI WIENER. AYE,
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BROUGH GIL. BLAKESPEAR
DOLLY! GONZALES. GROVE. JONES.
LAYERED WHEN BY THE AYE.
WELCOME. ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE OUT
IN 25, FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM 27,
28, 29 AND 30. WE'LL MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 25. THIS IS SP 691
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO WITH THE
CLERK. PLEASE READ THE BILL.
SENATE BILL 691 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO IN EQUALING TWO STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION, SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. SB 691 IS
A SIMPLE BILL THAT WOULD ADD TO
STUDENTS TO THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION TO ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
. THERE'S ONE CURRENTLY ON THE
BOARD. I THINK IT WOULD EMPOWER
YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE MORE ACTIVE
IN CRAFTING EDUCATION POLICY,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE ANY FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEN ON THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALRIGHT, I BROUGHT A GILL
ALRIGHT ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
ALRIGHT BLACK SPEAR. ALRIGHT,
BRADFORD. HELLO. AYE, CORTESI. I
DOLLY. DODD. DELI. NO DOT I
DAZZLE. AYE, EGGMAN. ALRIGHT
GLASER. ALRIGHT GONZALES. GROVE.
NO HADO. ALL RIGHT, JONES. NO,
LORD. I HUMAN. ALRIGHT MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT MENJIVAR. ALL RIGHT,
MAN. NEWMAN. I WIN. NO NEIL Ó.
KNOW WHAT EUROBORG BY THE
ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT,
ROTH. RUBIO. ALL RIGHT, SO YOU
ARE TOE NÓ SKINNER. SMALL WORLD,
CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. ALRIGHT
AMBERG. ALRIGHT, WE'LL HAVE AYE,
WIENER. WILK. NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD. I.
GONZALES. OR CHILD, BORG. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 7. THE MEASURE
PASSES WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 27. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
THE BILL. SENATE BILL 764 BY
SENATOR BUT BY THE INOCULATED
MINERS, SENATOR PADILLA MEMBERS,
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR PRESIDENT. SB 764 IS
THE CHILD CONTENT CREATOR RIGHTS
ACT, WHICH WILL REQUIRE FAMILY
CONTENT CREATORS WHO ARE
COMPENSATED FOR FILMING THEIR
MINOR CHILDREN. IN MORE THAN 30%
OF THEIR CONTENT TO SET ASIDE A
PERCENTAGE OF THAT REVENUE IN A
TRUST THAT MINOR CAN ACCESS WHEN
THEY REACH THE AGE OF MAJORITY.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, WELL,
CALIFORNIA'S GROUNDBREAKING
COOGAN AC NEARLY THREE QUARTERS
OF A CENTURY AGO, PROTECTS CHILD
ACTORS IN CALIFORNIA OPERATING
UNDER CONTRACT WHO ARE FILMED,
BUT THESE PROTECTIONS DO NOT
EXTENT TO THE EMERGING
CIRCUMSTANCE WE FACE TODAY, THE
RISE OF SOCIAL MEDIA HAS SEEN
FAMILY CONTENT CREATORS EXPLODE.
WITH MANY PARENTS FILMING THEIR
DAILY LIVES AND EARNING
THOUSANDS, THOUSANDS AND MORE
DOLLARS IN REVENUE, SPONSORSHIPS
AND ADVERTISING. SOME REGULARLY
INCLUDE THEIR CHILDREN IN THIS
CONTENT, INCLUDING FILMING THE
INTIMATE DETAILS OF THEIR
PERSONAL LIVES FOR THEIR
AUDIENCE OF MILLIONS TO SEE. IN
ADDITION, THIS RAISES SERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE DRAFTED INTO
THIS EMERGING ENTERTAINMENT
LANDSCAPE. VIDEOS ABOUT PEAK
MOMENTS SUCH AS NEW HOMES,
PREGNANCY, NEW BABIES GET MORE
VIEWS INCENTIVIZING FAMILIES TO
POST MORE VIDEOS OF THEIR
CHILDREN AND SACRIFICING THEIR
PRIVACY. SP 764 SIMPLY APPLIES
THE COOGAN ACT PROTECTIONS TO
MODERN ENTERTAINMENT AND
PERFORMERS AND SOCIAL MEDIA
BECOMES EVEN MORE INTEGRATED
INTO OUR DAILY LIFE AND A
GROWING SHARE OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT LANDSCAPE. WE NEED
TO UPDATE OUR HARD FOUGHT LABOR
PROVISIONS AND SAFEGUARD THE
FINANCIAL FUTURE OF THESE
PERFORMERS. SP 764 WOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT CHILDREN DESERVE
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
COMPENSATION FOR BEING FILLED.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR PADILLA. ANY
DISCUSSION ANY FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE MEMBERS? SEE NO
MICROPHONES UP, SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HOW
ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A GIRL.
ALRIGHT, ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT
ASHBY. ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT
BECKER. ALRIGHT BLAKESPEAR.
ALRIGHT, BRADFORD. OH, ALRIGHT,
CORTESI. ALRIGHT, DOLLY! DODD. I
DO THAT SO ALRIGHT, EGGMAN.
GLASER. ALRIGHT GONZALES. GROVE.
DODD, Ó. ALL RIGHT, JONES. AYE,
LAIRD. LIMÓN HI MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT, MENJIVAR. ALL RIGHT,
MAN. NEWMAN. I WIN. NEIL Ó.
WHAT'S HORRIBLE HI, PADILLA.
ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. HI, ROD.
RUBIO. ALL RIGHT, SO YOU ARE TOE
SKINNER. ALRIGHT, SMALL WORK
WITH US. ALRIGHT, STERN. ALL
RIGHT, AMBER. ALRIGHT, WELL, HOB
HI WIENER. AYE, WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DELI.
GONZALES. GROVE. I WHEN NEELA.
SO YOUR TOE WILK. VOTE OF 34 TO
0 IF THE MEASURE PASSES MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 28 BY SENATOR
CAVALLERO SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 768 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO AND THAT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENT EQUALITY, SENATOR
CAVALLERO. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. UM THIS
MEMBERS, THIS CONTINUES THE SAGA
OF ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SOME
REGIONS ARE ACTUALLY DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER REGIONS. UM IN 2013
SB 743 WAS SIGNED INTO LAW AND
IT'S AND IT ESTABLISHED A
SPECIAL ADMINISTRATIVE AND
JUDICIAL REVIEW PROCESS UNDER
SEQUA FOR THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
TO STREAMLINE THE DEVELOPMENT
AND CONSTRUCTION OF THE GOLDEN
ONE CENTER. SO FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE GONE TO THE GOLDEN ONE
CENTER YOU KNOW IT IS AN INFILL
PROJECT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CITY AND THE, UM THE BILL TASK,
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH TO DEVELOP
NEW GUIDELINES TO REPLACE THE
CURRENT CRITERIA USED TO MEASURE
TRANSPORTATION IMPACTS. IN OTHER
WORDS, IF YOU BUILT THAT
FACILITY, ACCORDING TO THE OLD
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM, IT COULD
NOT BE DONE BECAUSE IT WAS GOING
TO INCREASE TRAFFIC IN THE
REGION. BUT BECAUSE OPR CAME UP
WITH A DIFFERENT SYSTEM, WHICH
IS VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED, THEY
GOT AROUND THAT THAT PROBLEM AND
CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
INFILL PROJECTS IN TRANSIT RICH
COMMUNITIES, AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WAS DONE IN THIS INSTANT.
BY A BUDGET BILL, WHICH TOOK THE
CONCEPT AND APPLIED IT TO THE
ENTIRE STATE. WE NOW HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE
DEVELOPMENT ALL OVER THE STATE
IN PARTICULAR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THAT HAVE TO MEET
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
GUIDELINES, WHICH MEANS THAT YOU
HAVE TO PUT IN TRANSIT. YOU HAVE
TO CREATE BICYCLE LANES. YOU
HAVE TO CREATE WALKING LANES.
ALL IS A WAY TO GET PEOPLE OUT
OF THEIR HOUSES. WHAT WHAT HAS
RESULTED BY THAT IS IT HAS
RESULTED IN A FEE. BECAUSE MANY
COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE TRANSIT
THEY BICYCLE PATH ISN'T GOING TO
MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE AND IN
SUBURBAN AND RURAL AREAS THIS VM
T APPLICATION RESULTS IN
INCREASED COST FOR DEVELOPMENT
AT THE EXACT SAME TIME THAT
WE'RE TELLING COMMUNITIES WE
NEED YOU TO BUILD TO PLAN AND
BUILD FOR HOUSING. WERE ALSO
SAYING, OH, BY THE WAY, YOU HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED BECAUSE IF YOU PUT THAT
HOUSE IN THAT LOCATION YOU'RE
GOING TO CREATE TRAFFIC. AND
COMMUTERS. MEMBERS WE KNOW. THAT
IN HIGHLY URBANIZED AREAS THAT
ARE NOT BUILDING ENOUGH HOUSING.
AND THAT PEOPLE ARE TRAVELING
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY FROM
FROM THEIR PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT
TO FIND A HOUSE THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD. MY DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR HAS SEEN THE IMPACT
OF THIS AND I KNOW IN MANY OF
YOUR DISTRICTS AS WELL. IN THIS
IN THE COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE. THE
UNIQUE SITUATION THAT WAS
CREATED IS THAT WHEN THE COUNTY
DECIDED THEY NEEDED TO IMPROVE
THE TRAFFIC ON THEIR HIGHWAY
SYSTEM, THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
UPGRADE THE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT WOULD INCREASE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. IN OTHER
WORDS, RIVERSIDE WAS STOPPED
FROM DOING A SAFETY IMPROVEMENT.
THEY KEEP PEOPLE SAFE ON THE
HIGHWAY BECAUSE OF VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. PEOPLE ARE TRAVELING
BECAUSE THEY CAN AFFORD A HOUSE
THERE. AND BY NOT FIXING THE
ROAD. WE DON'T IMPROVE SAFETY
AND WE DON'T DO ANYTHING TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM TRAVELING TO WHERE
THEY CAN AFFORD TO BUY. THE BILL
BASICALLY IS A STUDY BILL NOW,
AND IT'S A STUDY BILL TO GET THE
AIR BOARD THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY, THE HOUSING AGENCY, ALL
THE SIT DOWN AND JUST SAY, LOOK,
WE'VE SET UP PRIORITIES THAT
DON'T MAKE SENSE. WE HAVE
PENALIZED COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
BUILDING THE HOUSING THAT'S
NEEDED IN OUR STATE. BUT WHO
ALSO ARE REQUIRED TO USE A MODEL
THAT DOESN'T WORK FOR THEM. IT
DOESN'T REDUCE TRAFFIC BY ADDING
A FEE ONTO A HOUSE. IT DOESN'T
IMPROVE TRAFFIC BY NOT ALLOWING
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS. UM WE NEED
THIS STUDY TO BE DONE SO WE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
INCENTIVIZED THE BUILDING OF
HOUSING? AND HOW CAN WE DO IT IN
A WAY THAT COMPLIES WITH SEQUA
AND THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF
RURAL AND SUBURBAN AREAS. AND
SO, UM, I BELIEVE IT CAN
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY IS NECESSARY
TO DRAW ATTENTION TO ANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE THE BMT
ANALYSIS AND THERE'S CLEAR
EVIDENCE GAP TO JUSTIFY LIMITING
OR EXCLUDING PROJECTS PROJECTS
FROM VM EMPTY, SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON THIS REALLY IMPORTANT. STUDY
WELL, THANK YOU, SENATOR
CABALLERO. I SEE MICROPHONES UP
FROM SENATOR ROTH AND SENATOR
DOLLY SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. I REALIZED IT'S
330 IN THE AFTERNOON. SO I'LL
TRY TO MAKE THIS BRIEF. YOU'VE
HEARD ME BEFORE. I LIVE IN
ENGLAND, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHERE WE BUILD HOMES WE BUILD
USED TO BE AFFORDABLE HOMES. UM
OUR POLICIES IN THE STATE ARE IN
SOMEWHAT OF A CONFLICT. WE OFTEN
INCENTIVIZED JOB GROWTH, JOB
RETENTION JOB EXPANSION IN THE
URBAN COASTAL AREAS WHERE THAT'S
WHERE JOBS HISTORICALLY HAVE
BEEN. AND WE TELL THE INLAND
PARTS OF THE STATE THROUGH THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT PROCESS TO BUILD
HOUSING. IN THIS CASE OF THE
CITY OF RIVERSIDE, THE ARENA
ALLOCATION IS 18,000 HOMES. WE
TELL THE INLAND PARTS TO BUILD
HOUSING. TO HOUSE THE WORKERS
WHO WORK ON THE COAST IN THE
URBAN AREAS. WE DON'T REQUIRE
THOSE URBAN COASTAL AREAS THAT
ARE GETTING MONEY FOR JOB
EXPANSION, JOB RECRUITMENT
RETENTION TO CERTIFY THAT THEY
WILL, EITHER THEY EITHER HAVE OR
WILL BUILD WORKER HOUSING. WE
USED THE REALLOCATION TO DRIVE
THE HOUSING TO THE INLAND PARTS
OF THE STATE. IN IN IN THE
INLAND PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE
I LIVE, THE TRANSIT DOESN'T WORK
. THE BUS LINES DON'T CAN
CONNECT WHERE THEY CROSS COUNTY
LINES AND YOU CANNOT TAKE THE
BUS TO GET FROM YOUR HOME TO
YOUR JOB EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY. IT WOULD PROBABLY
TAKE FOUR OR FIVE HOURS TO GET
FROM PLACES IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY,
TWO JOBS AND ORANGE COUNTY OR IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THE TRAIN
DOESN'T WORK BECAUSE THE TRAIN.
THE PASSENGER TRAINS USE THE
FREIGHT LINES AND SO THE TRAIN
SERVICES NOT AS FREQUENT AS IT
SHOULD BE. AND YOU CERTAINLY
CAN'T GET BACK MIDDAY. IF YOUR
CHILD GETS SICK, OR YOU HAVE TO
GET HOME FOR SOME OTHER REASON.
SO OUR POLICIES DON'T WORK. WE
CAN'T SEEM TO GET THEM CONNECTED
WITH THIS VEHICLE. MILES
TRAVELED. I WILL GIVE YOU A
RECENT EXAMPLE OF A HIGHWAY
EXPANSION PROJECT IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY, THE 91 TO 15. IT WAS AN
EXPANSION PROJECT THAT WAS
MULTIPLE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY APPROVED.
AND THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES ARE CTC AND THE ONE IN
DECEMBER, LATINO COUNTY WHEN IT
WENT BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TO GET
AN ALLOCATION OF 200 PLUS
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION OF
THAT PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
CONSTRUCTION MONEY, AND THE
REQUEST WAS DENIED. IT WAS
DENIED BECAUSE THE PROJECT
INCREASES VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
. WELL, OF COURSE IT INCREASES
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED WHEN YOU
DIRECT THE HOUSING BE BUILT AND
THE JOBS AROUND THE COAST, EVERY
HOUSE YOU BUILD WILL INCREASE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED NOW I
WILL TELL YOU THAT
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION WISELY
RECONSIDERED THAT DECISION, AND
I BELIEVE IT WAS JUST LAST WEEK.
TOWARD THE END. THEY APPROVED
THAT PROJECT. BUT THE INITIAL
OUTCOME WAS OUTRAGEOUS. YOU YOUR
POLICIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MUST INTEGRATE AND
THEY MUST WORK. AND IN THIS
CASE, THEY OBVIOUSLY DON'T I
SUGGEST THAT WE GIVE THE SENATOR
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I
VOTE ON THIS BILL. IT'S A GOOD
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ROTH. FOR THOSE
BRIEF REMARKS, SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
I ACTUALLY VOTED FOR THE BILL IN
COMMITTEE AND MY DISTRIBUTE AS
EVERYBODY KNOWS, IS THE LARGEST
DISTRICT IN THE STATE AND
VEHICLE. MILES TRAVELED
PENALIZES US. NUMBER ONE. WE
HAVE TO TRAVEL NUMBER TWO. WE
DON'T HAVE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
THAT WORKS, UM WITH VERY
SPRAWLED OUT COMMUNITIES, BUT
AND THE SAME TIME. UM A LOT A
LOT OF PARTS OF MY DISTRICT,
WHICH ARE HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA. UM, HAVE CHECK PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THAT PEOPLE DON'T
USE. SO I'M JUST GOING TO SAY I
NOTICED THAT NO REPUBLICANS HAVE
VOTED FOR THIS BILL. OBVIOUSLY
MY DISTRICT HATES VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED PERIOD BECAUSE THEY ALL
TRAVEL AND TAXING THOSE MILES OR
NOT HAVING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. BUT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE HAVE A
COUPLE OF REASONS. NUMBER ONE. I
THINK THAT WE'VE GOT IT WRONG
WHEN PEOPLE AREN'T USING OUR
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION, AND WE'RE
SAYING THEY ARE AND WE'RE MAKING
IT MAKING DECISIONS ON THAT. AT
THE SAME TIME, WE'RE PUTTING
MORE PEOPLE ON THE ROAD TO GET
TO THEIR WORK IN AFFORDABLE
AREAS, SO I HAVE APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON A VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUE. UM BUT WE NEED
THAT INFORMATION. IF WE'RE
REALLY GONNA DO IT, RIGHT. WE
NEED TO GET GOOD INFORMATION AND
FIND OUT WHAT PEOPLE ARE REALLY
DOING. AND IT'S CONTRARY TO WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN. TRYING
TO PUSH THEM TO DO AND WE'RE
HAVING THESE CONFLICTS. SO I'M
GOING TO VOTE FOR THE BILL. I'M
HOPING SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
MY SIDE OF THE AISLE WILL
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS GOOD WILL
BE GOOD INFORMATION TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE ON WHAT
PEOPLE ARE REALLY DOING IT
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE WANT THEM
TO DO. THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT FOR THOSE REASONS.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
AGAIN TODAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DOLLY ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SCENE NINE. SENATOR CABALLERO,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING ME IN
URGING SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. YOU
KNOW, UM ULTIMATELY, WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS MAKE OUR POLICIES
MAKE SENSE. AND AS I WAS LOOKING
AROUND, UM AND IT URGENTLY
IMPLORING THE COASTAL REGIONS TO
SUPPORT THIS THIS BILL, UM THAT
THE ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH ARE WE
GOING TO GO BEYOND WHAT WE'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW AND CREATE A
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT WILL
MOVE CALIFORNIANS TO WHEREVER
THEY WANT TO GO. AND RIGHT NOW,
ALL OF OUR POLICIES REALLY LIMIT
OUR TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES FROM
REACHING OUT INTO THE INTO NEW
REGIONS AND CREATING
PARTNERSHIPS AND MY HOPE OUT OF
THIS STUDY. BILL IS IT WILL COME
UP WITH A HORSE HOST OF THINGS
THAT IF THIS IS HAPPENING IN
YOUR COUNTY, YOU DON'T HAVE THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION THERE ARE
THERE. IT'S A JOB. POOR AREA.
THE MONEY THAT THE STATE IS
PUTTING OUT FOR JOB CREATION IS
GOING TO, UM, AREAS THAT ARE NOT
PRODUCING THE HOUSING. IF WE CAN
GET ALL OF THIS DATA GET
TOGETHER, WE CAN MAKE IT MAKE
SENSE IN A WAY THAT HELPS US TO
BUILD HOUSING HELPS US TO MOVE
PEOPLE, UM ALL OVER THE STATE.
AND WITH THAT, I WOULD RESPECT
REALLY. AS FOR YOUR I VOTE
DEBATE HAVE BEING SEATS.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALRIGHT ALVARADO GIL.
ALRIGHT ARCHULETTA ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
ALRIGHT BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT,
BRADFORD. ALRIGHT, CABALLERO.
AYE, CORTESI. I DOLLY ALRIGHT,
DODD, DURAZO. ACKMAN. I WANT
GLASER. ALRIGHT GONZALES.
GROWTH. I HAD. OH, ALRIGHT,
JONES. NO, LORD. LIMÓN HI
MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR. ALL RIGHT,
MAN. NEWMAN. ALRIGHT WHEN NO
NEIL Ó. MY CHILD BUG. NO. BY
THE ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT,
ROTH. RUBIO. SO YOUR TOE
SKINNER. SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE,
STERN. HI I'M BERT. I HA! AYE,
WIENER. I WELCOME NÓ. IT'S
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GONZALES MCGUIRE I KNEEL Ó. I
THREW VÚI. ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE.
ON A VOTE OF 34 TO 4. THE
MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GONNA MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 29 BY SENATOR
LIMÓN. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 782 BY SENATOR
LEHMAN EQUALING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT, SENATOR LIMÓN. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. SP
782 REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF THE
GOVERNOR TO MAINTAIN ON ITS
WEBSITE. A LIST OF ALL STATE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS,
INCLUDING THE PURPOSE MEMBERSHIP
LIST AND INFORMATION WHEN THEY
CONVENE. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
AN ANNUAL REPORT WITH AGGREGATE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OF
INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED TO THE
STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSION. SB
72 HAS RECEIVED STRONG BY THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. YEARS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LIMÓN ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEN UN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT GIL. ALRIGHT
ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY. AYE,
ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
BLAKESPEAR ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT, CORTESI. HI,
DOLLY. DODD. ALRIGHT, DUDE, I SO
ALRIGHT, EGGMAN. GLASER.
GONZALES. GROW. TODD Ó. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. AYE, LAIRD.
ALRIGHT, LIMÓN. MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT, MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT, MAN.
NEWMAN. I WIN. ALRIGHT, NILO.
ALRIGHT. WHAT'S YOUR BOOK? ALL
RIGHT BY THE ALRIGHT PORTANTINO.
ROTH. RUBIO. ALL RIGHT, SO YOU
ARE TOE ALRIGHT SKINNER.
ALRIGHT, SMALL WORK WITH US.
ALRIGHT, STERN. HI, AMBER. I
WILL. HA! WIENER. I WELCOME
ALRIGHT. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER. AYE, BRADFORD.
AYE. GONZALES. GROVE.
SENATOR LIMÓN MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS. WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS
REMAINING, SO LET'S TAKE A
BREATH. THE NEXT FIVE ARE GOING
TO BE FILED ON 30, 32, 33, 34
AND 36. SO NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
30 SP 820 BY SENATOR ALVARADO
GIL. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
CENTERVILLE 820 BY SENATOR
ALVARADO GILL AND ACCORDING TO
CANNABIS, SENATOR ALVARADO GIL.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL 820. THIS
IS A BILL THAT ADOPTS THE SAME
CIVIL ASSET FORFEITURE PROCESS
CURRENTLY APPLICABLE TO
UNLICENSED MANUFACTURING OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. THIS WOULD
APPLY TO UNLICENSED COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS ACTIVITIES WITH MORE
THAN 1000 LIVE PLANTS UPON A
JUDGMENT IN FAVOR OF THE
FORFEITURE UNDER SB 820, THE
SEIZED PROPERTY WOULD BE SOLD AT
PUBLIC AUCTION. WITH 85% OF THE
PROCEEDS GOING TO A REINVESTMENT
OF THE CANNABIS CONTROL FUND TO
SUPPORT CANNABIS EQUITY
BUSINESSES. QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE COME OUT. SO
CLAIRE EFFORT TO CLARIFY THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT A
WARRANT ISSUED BY A JUDGE UPON
PROBABLE CAUSE BE OBTAINED
BEFORE ANY PROPERTY CAN BE
SEIZED UNDER THE BILL. THIS ALSO
CREATES A VERY SPECIFIC LIST OF
ITEMS USED IN UNLICENSED
CANNABIS OPERATIONS THAT WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THE SEIZURE. IT DOES
PROHIBIT THE SEIZURE OF VEHICLES
CARRYING CANNABIS OR CANNABIS
PRODUCTS VALUED AT LESS THAN
5000, AS WELL AS CLARIFICATION
THAT THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE REAL
PROPERTY UNDER THE SEIZURE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
MEASURES ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEE NO OBJECTION IS
39 NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
EXCUSE ME. I DIDN'T SEE AN
OBJECTION IN THE BACK. SO WE'RE
GOING TO CALL THE ROLL
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A GILL.
ALRIGHT ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY.
HI, ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
BLAKESPEAR ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ALRIGHT, CABALLERO. CORTEZ E.
ALRIGHT, DOLLY! DODD. DOLLY I.
DODD. I DO THAT SO HAGMAN.
ALRIGHT GLASER. GONZALES.
BROUGH. ALL RIGHT, TODD Ó. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. AYE, LAIRD. AYE,
LIMÓN. HI MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT MEN. ALL
RIGHT, NEWMAN. ALRIGHT WHEN
ALRIGHT, NILO. ALL RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT BY THE ALRIGHT PORTANTINO.
ALRIGHT, ROTH. HI, RUBIO.
ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE AYE,
SKINNER. SMALLER CUEVAS. STERN.
ALL RIGHT NUMBER ALRIGHT, WELL
HA AYE, WIENER. ALRIGHT, WILK.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER. I CABALLERO.
AYE. SO GONZALES. SKINNER.
SMALLER CUEVAS. ALRIGHT AND A
VOTE OF 36 TO 0. THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO MEASURES THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT ON CALL. WE HAVE TWO OF
THEM. TO BEGIN WITH FILE ITEMS
16 SB FIVE. 54 SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. GONZALES. WHAT'S
YOUR BOOK? BY THE ALL RIGHT. ON
A VOTE OF 32 TO 6. THE MEASURE
PASSES NEXT. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
FILE ITEM 29. SP 782. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GONZALES.
ROLLED. ALL RIGHT. AND A VOTE OF
39 TO 0. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM. 32 SP SEVEN BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPHERE SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ.
CENTREVILLE SEVEN BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR IN EQUAL INTO
HOUSING. SENATOR BLAKE SPHERE.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN, WHICH WILL
CLARIFY EXISTING STATUTES
REGARDING REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REPORTING OF
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSING
PRODUCTION. SB SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REPORT THE
CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY THAT
THEY ISSUE FOR EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME HOUSING CERTIFICATES OF
OCCUPANCY INDICATE THAT
CONSTRUCTION IS COMPLETE, AND
THE UNIT IS READY TO BE
OCCUPIED. SINCE 2017. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN MAJOR
STRIDES TO HOLD LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
INCREASING HOUSING PRODUCTION.
WHILE TRACKING OF LOCALS.
HOUSING PRODUCTION IS ROBUST.
THERE IS A NEED TO ENHANCE
TRACKING OF THE TYPE OF HOUSING
PRODUCTION THAT CALIFORNIA'S
MOST URGENTLY NEED. SB SEVEN
WILL ADDRESS THIS NEED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BLAKE SPIRIT,
SENATOR DOLLY! THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT HAVE AMENDMENTS AT THE
DESK. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ THE
AMENDMENTS. AMENDMENT BY SENATOR
DELI SET ONE. SENATOR DOLLY THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. I
RISE TODAY TO OFFER AN AMENDMENT
TO SP SEVEN. WE MUST STOP THE
DANGEROUS PRACTICE OF RELEASING
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS INTO
OUR COMMUNITIES ON TRANSIENT
STATUS. THIS PRACTICE IS
UNCOMFORTABLE AND DANGEROUS,
ACCORDING TO LIBERTY HEALTHCARE
75. OF SEXUALLY, UH. VIOLENT
PREDATORS RELEASED ON TRANSIT
STUDIES FAILED TO TRANSITION
SUCCESSFULLY AND WE'RE RE
HOSPITALIST OR REVOKED DUE TO
SERIOUS VIOLATIONS. WE KNOW THAT
DANGEROUS WE KNOW THE DANGERS OF
THESE PREDATORS POSE WE CAN AND
MUST DO BETTER INSTEAD OF GIVING
THEM AN RV AND JUST DUMPING THEM
IN THE COMMUNITY IF THE OFFENDER
CANNOT BE PLACED IN A RESIDENT
HOUSE, THEN ON STATE, WE SHOULD
HOUSE THEM ON STATE PROPERTY
WHERE THAT STATE PERSONNEL CAN
CLOSELY MONITOR THEM. LIBERTY
HEALTHCARE HAS TESTIFIED THAT IS
EASIER TO MONITOR THE OFFENDERS.
IN A FIXED RESIDENTS WITH
HARDWIRE PHONE AND INTERNET
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS
AREN'T YOUR AVERAGE FELONS.
WHILE THERE ARE GREAT NUMBER IN
NUMBERS, THEY POSE GREATER THAN
AVERAGE RISK OF REOFFENDING. THE
STATE'S OBLIGATION IS TO
MINIMIZE THAT RISK. I KNOW THAT
MY DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES LIKE
LIKELY WILL TABLE THIS MOTION
WITHOUT DEBATE. THAT THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE SAME AMENDMENT
LAST YEAR BY VOTING TO TABLE
THIS MOTION. YOU ARE VOTING TO
REJECT CONSIDERATION OF THIS
MEASURE. I SAY THIS TO YOU, MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE. THIS IS A GROWING
PROBLEM. AT LEAST LET'S DEBATE
THE ISSUE SO CALIFORNIANS CAN
SEE WHERE WE STAND ON PROTECTING
THE PEOPLE IN THE IN OUR
DISTRICTS FROM THIS VERY REAL
THREAT. MEMBERS I'VE HAD MANY OF
THESE FOLKS. PLACED IN MY
DISTRICT, NOT THE DISTRICTS.
THEY COME FROM, BECAUSE IT'S A
RURAL AREA, SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. MEMBER SENATOR DOLLY
HAS PLACED AMENDMENTS ON THE
FLOOR. THAT'S THE NEXT ONE. I
RECOGNIZE SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MR. PRESIDENT MR
PRESIDENT, BILLS FOCUSED ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR WORKING
FAMILIES AND SENIORS. THE
AMENDMENTS AREN'T REMAINED TO
THE BILL AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AMENDMENTS
BE LAID ON THE TABLE AND WITH
RESPECT. RESPECT FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AND I
VOTE EASIER FOR ME TO SAY
SENATOR MCGUIRE IS MOVED TO LAY
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
IT'S A NON DEBATABLE MOTION
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A GILL.
ALRIGHT, ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
ALRIGHT BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT,
BRADFORD. ALRIGHT, CABALLERO.
ALRIGHT CORTEZ E. ALRIGHT,
DOLLY! NO, DAD. ALRIGHT, SO
ALRIGHT, EGGMAN. GLASER
GONZALES. GROVE. TODD O GROVE,
NO HØI LAYERED. EXCUSE ME.
JONES. NO, LORD, I LIMÓN ALRIGHT
MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT MEN, JABBAR.
MAN. ALL RIGHT, NEWMAN. I WIN.
NÓ NILO. NO TROUBLE. NÓ ALRIGHT
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO.
ALRIGHT. SEE ARTO. NÓ SKINNER.
ALRIGHT, SMALL CUEVAS. ALRIGHT,
STERN. ALL RIGHT NUMBER AHA!
ALRIGHT WIENER. I WELCOME NO,
IT'S CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBER.
GONZALES. BEN JABBAR? AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 8. THE AMENDMENTS
ARE PLACED ON THE TABLE WILL
MOVE BACK TO THE MAIN MOTION,
WHICH IS THE PASSAGE OF SB
NUMBER SEVEN BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT ON FILE. I'M 32 SB
SEVEN. THE LANGUAGE THAT'S IN
THE BILL. CURRENTLY I BELIEVE IS
UNOBJECTIONABLE. BUT IT IS A GUT
AND AMEND, AND THIS LANGUAGE HAS
NOT BEEN THROUGH ANY POLICY
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE SENATE. SO
I'M GOING TO ENCOURAGE, UH,
LAYING OFF ON THIS VOTE. JUST IN
CASE IT GOES TO THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE ASSEMBLY MESSES IT UP. SO WE
DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN. AND
SO I'M GONNA ASK FOR AN
ABSTENTION ON THIS ON THIS VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NON
SENATOR BLAKE SPERRY MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU. YES THIS BILL IS MUCH
REDUCED FROM ITS ORIGINAL GOALS,
BUT IT IS STILL IMPORTANT AND IT
IS SUPPORTED BY A LARGE NUMBER
OF GROUPS, WHICH I WILL NOT READ
OUT. UM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE DEBATE HAVING SEATS.
THE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A
GIRL. ALRIGHT, ARCHULETTA.
ALRIGHT ASHBY. ALRIGHT ATKINS.
ALRIGHT BECKER. BLAKESPEAR
ALRIGHT, BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
ALRIGHT CORTEZ E. HI, DOLLY.
DODD. ALRIGHT DURAZO. ALRIGHT,
EGGMAN. ALRIGHT GLASER. ALRIGHT
GONZALES. GROVE. TODD Ó. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. LAYERED AYE,
LIMÓN. ALRIGHT MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. ALL RIGHT, MAN. HI,
NEWMAN. ALRIGHT WHEN HELLO.
WHAT'S YOUR BUG? BY THE ALRIGHT
PORTANTINO. AYE, ROTH. AYE,
RUBIO. ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE
SKINNER. AYE, SMALLER CUEVAS.
ALRIGHT, STERN. I AM BERG. I HAB
ALRIGHT WIENER. AYE, WILK.
SCOTT, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER. I DOLLY.
GONZALES. GROVE. JOHNS. WHEN
HELLO. TROUBLE. SO YOUR TOE
WILK. I WANNA VOTE OF 32 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES. AND IN THE
WORDS OF THE SENATOR FROM SAN
DIEGO. SENATOR BLAKE SPREAD.
DON'T LET THE ASSEMBLY MESS THIS
UP. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM. 33 THIS IS SP
37 BY SENATOR CABALLERO.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 37 BY SENATOR CABALLERO AND
EQUALLY INTO HOMELESSNESS,
SENATOR CAVIAR OH, THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SP 38, WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH THE OLDER ADULTS AND
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES,
DISTANCE DISABILITIES HOUSING
STABILITY ACT. TO OFFER
COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS, CONTINUUM OF CARE
AND OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE SHALLOW
SUBSIDIES FOR VULNERABLE OLDER
ADULTS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES AT RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS MEMBERS, THE LARGEST
DEMOGRAPHIC POPULATION THAT IS
FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS ARE
ADULTS OVER THE AGE OF 55. AND
WE KNOW THIS IS HAPPENING
BECAUSE THEY'VE RETIRED. THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS AREN'T
SUFFICIENT. THEY END UP WITH A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY OR GET EVICTED
FROM THEIR HOUSING. AND THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW THEY'RE ON THE
STREETS, AND THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES. WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION AS A SOCIETY TO
TREAT HER ELDERLY WITH GREAT
RESPECT. UM A LOT OF TIMES THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN, AND IN THIS
INSTANCE WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT ARE THE STRATEGIES TO KEEP
THEM HOUSED SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T END UP ON
THE STREETS. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE NARROW THE BILL TO A
PILOT PROGRAM TO REDUCE THE
BILLS. FISCAL IMPACT IN THE
AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE COST OF
DEVELOPING AND ADMINISTERING THE
PROGRAM, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CABALLERO. AND TO BE
CLEAR THIS IS SENATE BILL 37 ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEN UN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A GIRL. AYE,
ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
BLAKESPEAR ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT, CORTESI. I
DOLLY. DODD. ALRIGHT, SO
ALRIGHT, EGGMAN. GLASER. ALL
RIGHT, GONZALEZ. GROVE. SHADOW.
ALL RIGHT, JONES. LAYERED ALL
RIGHT, LEMON. ALRIGHT MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT, MENJIVAR. ALL RIGHT,
MAN. ALL RIGHT, NEWMAN. I WIN.
HELLO. TROUBLE. ALL RIGHT BY THE
ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT,
ROTH. RUBIO. ALRIGHT, SO YOUR
TOE AYE, SKINNER. ALRIGHT,
SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE, STERN.
ALRIGHT. HAMBURG. WHAT HAPPENED?
WIENER. ALL RIGHT. WELCOME.
ALRIGHT, LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER. I DOLLY.
GONZALEZ. GROVE. JONES. I WHEN
AYE, NILO. HAMBURG. AYE. AND A
VOTE OF 36 TO 0. THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS. WE HAVE FIVE
BILLS LEFT. THE ORDER IN WHICH
WE'LL HEAR THEM ARE THE
FOLLOWING FILE ITEM 34. 36 THAT
WILL MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM 14.
25 AND 31 NEXT STEP. FILE ITEM
34 BY SENATOR SKINNER. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ CENTERVILLE 59 BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS, SENATOR
SKINNER, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS KNOW WHEN WE
WALK INTO A RESTROOM, ESPECIALLY
A PUBLIC RESTROOM. WE EXPECT
THAT THE SUPPLIES FOR A SANITARY
EXPERIENCE WILL BE PROVIDED SOAP
WATER TOILET PAPER THOSE ARE
EXPECTED BUT FOR HALF THE
POPULATION, MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS
ARE A BASIC NEED FOR A NORMAL
REGULAR BODILY FUNCTION. WHAT S
B 59 WILL DO IS ENSURE THAT
RESTROOMS IN OUR STATE FUNDED
BUILDINGS PROVIDE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS JUST AS THEY PROVIDE
TOILET PAPER, SOAP AND WATER,
ETCETERA. CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
. ENDED THE TAX ON MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS. WE REQUIRE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS TO BE PROVIDED FREE AT
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS. GRADE. 3 TO
12 ALSO RCS US AND OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO SP 59 WILL JUST
ENSURE THAT OUR STATE BUILDINGS
HAVE THE SAME THING. SB 59
PROMOTES EQUITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THAT MEN STRAIGHT
PERIOD. AND I ASKED FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEN UN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. ALRIGHT, I
BROUGHT A GILL. ALRIGHT,
ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
I LIKE SPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
ALRIGHT, CABALLERO. ALRIGHT
CORTEZ E. ALRIGHT, DOLLY! DODD.
ALRIGHT DO THAT SO ALRIGHT,
EGGMAN. ALRIGHT GLASER. ALRIGHT
GONZALES. GROVE. NO. ALL RIGHT,
JONES. LAYERED ALRIGHT LIMÓN.
ALRIGHT MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT MEN,
JABBAR. ALL RIGHT, MAN. ALL
RIGHT, NEWMAN, ALRIGHT WHEN
HELLO. TROUBLE. BY THE HI,
PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT, ROTH.
RUBIO. I SEE ARTO. SKINNER. AYE,
SMALLER CUEVAS. ALRIGHT, STERN.
ALRIGHT. HAMBURG. ALRIGHT, WELL
HA WIENER. I WELCOME. I CALLED
THE ABSENT MEMBERS, DOLLY!
GONZALES. GROVE. JONES. WHEN
NILO. TRIBAL SO YOUR TOE. AND A
VOTE OF 32 TO 0. THE MEASURE
PASSES NEXT STEP. FILE ITEM 36
BY SENATOR UMBERG SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 379 BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND EQUALLY INTO
PRISONS. SENATOR HAMBURG. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, UM, PRESENTING SP
379 THE ACCOUNTABILITY LETTER
BANK. THE GENESIS. THIS BILL WAS
A VISIT TO DONOVAN STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. SEVERAL
SEVERAL OF YOU WERE THERE AND
MEETING WITH VARIOUS FOLKS ARE
INCARCERATED. SOME OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAD INTERACTED WITH
THEIR VICTIMS AND FOUND IT TO BE
A POSITIVE EXPERIENCE, BOTH FOR
THE VICTIMS AS WELL AS FOR THOSE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED. HOWEVER
SOME WISH TO CONTACT THEIR
VICTIMS AND, UNDERSTANDABLY,
THERE'S NO METHOD TO DO SO. UM
AND IN FACT, SOME VICTIMS DON'T
WISH TO HAVE ANY CONTACT WITH
THOSE WHO ARE THE PERPETRATORS
OF THE CRIMES THAT CREATED THEM
AS VICTIMS. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS THE BASICALLY CREATE AN
ESCROW OR A BANK WHERE SOMEONE
WHO WAS INCARCERATED CAN SUBMIT
A COMMUNICATION CAN SUBMIT A
LETTER AND THEN THE PERSON OR
PERSONS WHO ARE VICTIMS CAN ASK
BASICALLY TO RECEIVE THE LETTER,
BUT THERE'S NO DIRECT CONTACT
BETWEEN THE TWO. I THINK IT'S A
HEALING AND RESTORATIVE MEASURES
URGENTLY. I VOTE THANK YOU,
SENATOR LUNDBERG ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. NO OBJECTIONS. I 39 NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE. HAVE A PRESENTATION BY ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS HERE. FILE ITEM.
14. THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL 827 BY SENATOR GLASER IN
EQUAL INTO TRANSPORTATION.
GLASER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. THIS BILL
WOULD APPLY EXISTING STATUTORY
AUTHORITY GRANTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION'S
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICTS. INSPECTOR
GENERAL SPECIFICALLY IT PROVIDES
THE BART I G WITH EXPLICIT
ACCESS TO RECORDS AND PROPERTY
AND ACCESS TO CONFIDENTIAL
RECORDS UNLESS STATE LAWS
EXPLICITLY PRECLUDES ACCESS. BUT
THAT WAS STRUCK. RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN I VOTE. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP. KIRK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. ALRIGHT
ALVARADO GIL. ALRIGHT
ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
ALRIGHT BLACK SPEAR. ALRIGHT,
BRADFORD. ZERO. ALRIGHT CORTEZ
E. ALRIGHT, DOLLY! ALRIGHT,
DODD. DO THAT, SO ALRIGHT,
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
ALL RIGHT, TODD Ó. ALL RIGHT,
JONES. MARRIED. I LEMON? ALRIGHT
MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT MEN, JABBAR.
ALL RIGHT, MAN. ALL RIGHT,
NEWMAN. WHEN. ALRIGHT, NILO.
ALRIGHT, OR CHILD BOOK. HI,
MARIA. ALRIGHT PORTANTINO.
ALRIGHT, ROTH. RUBIO. ALL RIGHT,
SO YOU ARE TOE ALRIGHT SKINNER.
ALRIGHT SMALLWOOD QUIVERS. AYE,
STERN. ALRIGHT. HAMBURG.
ALRIGHT, WELL, HOB AYE, WIENER.
I WELCOME I CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD. HI. GONZALES.
JONES. AYE, NEWMAN. I 39 TO 0.
MEASURES ADOPTED MOVING ON NOW
TO FILE ITEM 26 SB 733, THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL 733
BY SENATOR GLASER IN AQUITAINE
TO CORRECTIONS CENTER GLASER.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. MEMBERS. WE'VE HAD
CONSIDERABLE DEBATE ON THIS
FLOOR ABOUT SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. AND FOR GOOD
REASON. IT'S A SYSTEM THAT MANY
OF US FROM WHATEVER PERSPECTIVE,
I THINK FEEL IS BROKEN. AND NOT
WORKING THE WAY IT SHOULD. THE
MEASURE BEFORE YOU THE HEART OF
THE CHALLENGE AND DECIDING AND
VOTING ON THESE NUMEROUS REFORMS
TO THIS AREA IS THAT WE'RE
REALLY LACKING IN DATA. ABOUT
WHO GOES TO SOLITARY FOR HOW
LONG? HOW MANY TIMES FOR WHAT
REASON, AND THAT WHEN YOU ASKED
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
THAT FACTUAL DATA SO WE COULD
MAKE GOOD CHOICES AS
POLICYMAKERS, UH, WE DON'T GET
THE INFORMATION BACK. FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS, BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, THEY'RE NOT
GIVING US THE INFORMATION FOR US
TO MAKE THE CHANGES THAT MANY ON
THIS FLOOR THINK ARE NECESSARY.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU IS ONLY A
DATA BILL. IT ONLY REQUESTS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION AND THE DATA THAT I
NOTED EARLIER WHO'S BEING SENT
TO SOLITARY? HOW LONG ARE THEY
BEING KEPT THERE? HOW OFTEN
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
THEY BEING SENT TO SOLITARY?
AND, OF COURSE WHY IT'S
JUSTIFIED ALONG WITH A NUMBER OF
OTHER DATA REQUESTS ABOUT THEIR
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE TO MENTAL
HEALTH CARE TO REHABILITATION.
Tð RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
SO THE BILL BEFORE YOU IS NOT
THE REFORM THAT MANY PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE US DO. BUT IT
IS SETTING A FOUNDATION FOR
THOSE CHOICES THAT YOU MAY WISH
TO MAKE TODAY TOMORROW NEXT YEAR
THIS YEAR OR NEXT YEAR WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR MY VOTE.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP THIS
SINNER SINCE SKINNER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AYE. I'M NOT
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL, AND THE
REASON IS THAT I THINK THAT IT'S
A MISTAKE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
BEGIN IN A POSITION WHERE WE PUT
INTO STATUTE REQUESTS FOR
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. ONCE WE START
THAT. ROUTE THEN WE'VE PRETTY
MUCH SAID THAT WE PRETTY MUCH
HAVE TO PASS A BILL IN ORDER TO
GET INFORMATION THAT IS
LEGITIMATELY OURS TO REQUEST.
NOW. I'M NOT AWARE YET. I AM NOT
QUESTIONING THE AUTHOR IN TERMS
OF HE MAY HAVE REQUESTED THAT
DATA. I DON'T KNOW WHETHER ANY
OF OUR COMMITTEES SAY PUBLIC
SAFETY OR BUDGET COMMITTEE HAVE.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER WE'VE BEEN
REFUSED, BUT I'M VERY HESITANT
TO PUT INTO STATUTE SOMETHING
THAT SAYS, UH, DEPARTMENT YOU
MUST GIVE US INFORMATION BECAUSE
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WHEN WE
ARE TRYING TO ANALYZE, UH,
POLICIES OR BUDGETARY ACTIONS WE
DESERVE. UM SO THAT IS WHY I
WILL NOT BE VOTING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK SEEING NONE.
CENTER GLASER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? LOOK, I WISH THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION BE RESPONSIVE TO
OUR REQUESTS. UM. MEMBERS AT
LEAST SOME OF THE MEMBERS THAT
WEREN'T RECENTLY ELECTED. NO.
WE'VE HAD SPIRITED DEBATES ON
THIS ISSUE FOR A LONG TIME. AND
YET, WHERE ARE THE WHERE IS THE
FACTUAL BASIS FOR DECIDING
WHETHER OR NOT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS RUNNING OUR
CORRECTIONS AGENCY
APPROPRIATELY? SO IN A IN A
PERFECT WORLD, WE WOULDN'T HAVE
TO. REQUESTS AND DEMAND IN
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS, BUT IT
UNDERSCORES THE IMPORTANCE OF US
AS POLICY MAKERS MAKING GOOD
CHOICES WITH REAL DATA AND
INFORMATION. I THINK THAT, AS I
SAID IN MY OPENING SEGREGATED
HOUSING. AS IT'S. IT'S AS IT'S
REFERRED TO UM, IS A SERIOUS
PENALTY ON SOMEONE IN OUR. IN
OUR PRISONS. SOMETIMES IT'S DONE
FOR THEIR SAFETY. SOMETIMES IT'S
DONE FOR THE SAFETY OF OTHERS,
BOTH INMATES AS WELL AS
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS, BUT WE
NEED TO HAVE A SHINING LIGHT ON
THE ON THE ON ON EXACTLY HOW
THEY'RE RUNNING THESE
INSTITUTIONS, AND THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL. THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT IT'S FOCUSED ON IT
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR
MY VOTE. THANK YOU AND I'LL
DEBATE HAS CEASED. SENATOR
CORTEZ. SO AH! ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL. PALIN. ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT
A GIRL. ALRIGHT, ARCHULETTA.
AYE, ASHBY. ALRIGHT ATKINS.
ALRIGHT BECKER. ALRIGHT BLACK
SPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD. HELLO.
ALRIGHT CORTEZ E. I REALLY DODD.
ALRIGHT, SO HAGMAN. GLASER.
GONZALES. GROW. SHADOW. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. MY LORD. LEHMAN
MCGUIRE LEMON, I MCGUIRE I
MENTION BAR. NO MAN. NEWMAN. I
WENT NILO. WHAT'S YOUR BOOK?
NEIL OI, WHICH ARE BOOK PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ALRIGHT, ROTH. RUBIO.
ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE ALRIGHT
SKINNER. SMALL WORLD, CUEVAS.
STERN. ALL RIGHT NUMBER ALRIGHT,
WAHA. ALRIGHT WIENER. I WELCOME
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD. DOLLY! AYE.
HAGMAN. GONZALES. GROVE. AYE,
LAIRD. WHEN I BUY THE ROTH.
SKINNER. SMALLER CUEVAS. 31 TO
1. THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED. 32 1.
THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED. MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM 31, SENATOR
GLASER. THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENSIBILITIES 75 BY SENATOR
GLASER INEQUITY INTO HEALTH AND
CARE FACILITIES. GLASER YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MANY OF US KNOW. I
CAN IMAGINE HOW STRESSFUL IT IS
TO NAVIGATE THE PROCESS OF
FINDING A SAFE SETTING FOR AN
AGING FAMILY MEMBER OR FRIEND
WHO NEEDS PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT.
REFERRAL AGENCIES ARE OFTEN USED
FOR THAT PURPOSE TO HELP
FAMILIES MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
THEY DO THAT BY LEARNING ABOUT A
SENIORS NEEDS AND THEN
CONNECTING THEM WITH A
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY THAT
HAS ROOMS OPEN AND IN SOME CASES
QUICKLY. HOWEVER CURRENT LAW
ONLY MINIMALLY REGULATES
REFERRAL AGENCIES. AND THIS BILL
ADDRESSES TWO ELEMENTS TO RAISE
THE BAR ON WHAT IS GOING ON
TODAY. NUMBER ONE. IT CREATES A
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENT THAT
DOESN'T EXIST TODAY. YOU HAVE TO
DISCLOSE UNDER THIS LEGISLATION.
UM WHETHER, UH, THAT YOU HAVE TO
GIVE CONSUMERS AND DISCLOSURE,
BUT YOU HAVE TO YEAH. EXCUSE ME.
LET ME SAY THIS AGAIN. THE
MEASURE WILL BAN CERTAIN
PRACTICES LIKE REFERRAL AGENCIES
FROM HAVING ANY DIRECT OR
INDIRECT FINANCIAL INTEREST IN
ANY MEDICAL FACILITY DOING
BUSINESS WITH THE LICENSEE. AH!
THERE ARE SOME OTHER DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL, BUT
THE OTHER ELEMENT OF THE BILL IS
A LICENSING REQUIREMENT THAT
DOESN'T EXIST TODAY. IT CREATES
A LICENSING REQUIREMENT FOR
REFERRAL AGENCIES. NOW THERE ARE
SOME WHO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL WHO FEEL THAT THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE MUCH MORE
EXTENSIVE THAN WHAT IS IN THE
BILL TODAY, AND I'VE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THOSE UH, THOSE
ENTITIES TO SEE IF WE CAN MAKE
THEM MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THE
LICENSING REQUIREMENT, BUT THE
MAIN OBJECTION IS THEY WANT TO
SEE IT GO FURTHER. THE BILL
TODAY DOES PROVIDE IMPORTANT
DISCLOSURES DOES THAT LICENSING
SCHEMES SO THAT THERE CAN BE
GREATER REVIEW OF THESE REFERRAL
AGENCIES? AND WITH THAT? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE. NO
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. THERE ARE OBJECTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CLICK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I, ALVARADO
GIL. ALRIGHT, ARCHULETTA.
ALRIGHT ASHBY. ALRIGHT ATKINS.
ALRIGHT BECKER. ALRIGHT BLACK
SPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT CORTEZ E.
ALRIGHT, DOLLY! ALRIGHT, DODD.
ALRIGHT, SO HAGMAN. GLASER.
ALRIGHT GONZALES. GROVE. ALL
RIGHT, TODD Ó. ALL RIGHT,
JONES. ALRIGHT, LAIRD. ALRIGHT,
HUMAN HI MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT,
MENJIVAR. MEN. NEWMAN. I WEN
HELLO. ALRIGHT. WHAT'S YOUR
BOOK? ALL RIGHT BY THE ALRIGHT
PORTANTINO. ALL RIGHT, ROB.
RUBIO. ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE
ALRIGHT SKINNER. SMALLER CUEVAS.
STERN. HAMBURG. ALRIGHT, WELL,
HOB WIENER. AYE, WILK. AYE. IT'S
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD. AYE. SO HAGMAN.
GONZALES. MENJIVAR. WHEN AYE,
SKINNER. SMALLER CUEVAS. STERN.
WHAT? HOW. VOTE IS 32 TO 0. THAT
MEASURE IS ADOPTED. GOING TO
TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE HERE, PLEASE.
AND YOU MAY NOTICE A CHANGE IN
PRESIDER.
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS. BEFORE THE
SENATE SENATOR ATKINS, THE DESK
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. WELL COLLEAGUES,
ACCORDING TO OUR MAJORITY LEADER
, WE DID SOME GREAT WORK TODAY,
SO THE GOOD NEWS IS OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION WILL BE SCHEDULED
FOR TOMORROW. TUESDAY JANUARY
30TH 2024 AT 11 AM NOT 10:11
A.M. WILL WORK THE FILE FOR
APPROXIMATELY AN HOUR TO 90
MINUTES. AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS. VERY
TIMELY TOMORROW. SO WITH THAT,
MR PRESIDENT, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ATKINS. THE
SENATE MEMBERS WILL BE ADJOURNED
. WE WILL RECONVENE TUESDAY AT
11 A.M. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.